je vais ouvrir le chat et on va partir
et on va partir dessus on va vérifier
que tout soit bon ça doit l'être
ça doit l'être et juste pour dire il ya
une petite pointe aujourd'hui que je
savais pas qu'ils m'avaient pas été
donné c'est qu'un match pour la
troisième place hors sa personne n'avait
prévenu je l' ai appris je l'a appris il
ya quelques secondes j'ai envie de vous
dire par ya quelques secondes en il ya
dix mille ou là j'ai envie de te dire il
ya un avion qui passe devant chez moi
ouais bah c'est un avion quoi donc ouais
à la finale ça l'a pas prise hop
maintenant c'est bon donc est-ce qu'il
ya déjà des gens dans le tchat
on va se suivre ça les partis qui sont
partis mais voilà donc on est bon il ya
tout qui est ouverte face on va suivre
le match ça va durer ça va durer le
temps que ça va durer tant qu'il ya
personne dans le tchat
ouais voilà ça y est rodolphe qui est
l'art de 9,3 jose hawks qui me dit ok
eft hasek salut way dont il ya le match
pour la troisième place
alors honnêtement les matches pour la
troisième place moi perso à titre
personnel une nouvelle fois j'ai jamais
été emballés dans quelques disciplines
que ce soit
donc on va commencer en mode voilà on
regarde un peu la partie en mode
discussion est ce que est ce que dans
les dents dans les sports en général
dans les compétitions en général vous
êtes hype et pour des matches pour la
troisième place ou fondamentalement vous
êtes en mode kev on en a rien à faire
pas un seul winner takes it all quoi et
ça lui arrive 1 2 3 alors ça peut être
important quand même ça fait marquer des
points dans le grand prix dont système
un peu compliqué des grand prix 1 dont
je vous ai déjà rapidement parler mais
bon voilà on a pas bac +5 en
en lecture de d'événements fidh dont
qu'on a on souffre un petit peu mais
match pour la 3e place j'ai toujours dit
de toute façon bonbons tu finis 2e
coiffer un turini tapez 1
comment dire vite ou on fait si tu fais
un format coupe c'est pourqui 1,2 en
fait est bon bah après tu as perdu en
demie c'est un français intéressant
sinon bah disons que pour moi c'est
ouais caisse quinn a retrouvé son regard
de tueuse a on va quand même être un peu
pour ben aicha lire les gars je vous le
dis tout de suite weichs ali vice
schalit qui est la vache à lait weiss
schalit qui allaient blanc va et schalit
qui développe son fou donc toujours le
contrôle du centre on regardera plus
attentivement la partie suivante si la
rencontre le coup oui mais en fait pour
moi en fait un match pour la troisième
place ça ça peut être un match de gala
sans enjeu ou les joues ça envoie un
petit peu comme en coupe du monde par
exemple en coupe du monde que ce soit de
rugby ou de foot c'est un match de gala
quoi c'est à dire que bon bah ça ça
envoie un peu ça joue un peu un peu un
peu le football ou le rugby champagne en
aux échecs là on a deux nous voilà des
finales un match fermé faudrait
peut-être ce soit un match où les
joueuses tu vois
joue d ouverture un peu un peu
différente je sais pas s'il y avait un
peu ce côté là tu vois en voyage de jeu
on joue moins sérieux nanani nanana
peut-être ce serait cool rb4 b5 je pense
pour essayer d'aller alors bk tuera à
six et la faut réussir à comprendre ce
que ça donne ce truc là parce que lui il
n'est pas heureux
alors si on réussit ce raf si on réussit
à faire des carabistouilles ça peut être
intéressant et il ya aussi peut-être des
carabistouilles sur le fou voyez c'est
ce fou enfermé devant les pions je passe
si vous avez vous voyez un peu ce genre
de schéma ça arrive dans mes parties se
fout qu'il y en c2 qui a l'air gentil
mais il est bloqué par le pion g6 pour
le retour et c'est un peu le parking
quoi en entrée gratuite sorties payantes
quoi il peut il peut se prendre le
parking dans la gueule
j'ai pas si vous le sentez ça le parking
vous sentez le parking où vous sentez
pas le parking
bk de jouer alors ça fait parking où ça
fait pas par king 6 thouars
ou pas
donc
dans le monde donc donc donc attendez un
faut que j'aille m faut que j'aille
mettre le truc à je vais faire ça je
vais faire ça je vais faire ça je vais
faire ça je vais faire ça en fait je
vais mettre lost losc est parti donc
elle fait pas au 6 mai au 5 alors
pourquoi il faut 5 justement c'était
pour pour garder les les cases de repli
du uss et salue mikami qui 18 s'allume
out ux aller garer en double file elle
s'en va a accru les coûts de la double
file
alors maintenant il ya un truc
intéressant à l'est qui trouve le coup
allez on trouve le kubang abanga qui
trouve la petite opportunité tactique là
dans le chat qui me trouve l'opportunité
tactique il y avait une petite
opportunité tactique sympa tosh qui va
rester après x f5 aller kim la trouve
qui fait de la tactique ici allez
bunga-bunga la tactique
voilà la tactique c'est weichs ali qui
l'a trouvé alors pourquoi ça marche
parce que plus on prend des cinq tours
prend à 8 tours prend 1,8 fou prend 1,5
gagne le cavalier et si elle prend 2 c
il va y avoir foule prend 17 et là ça
fait mal b5 excellent coup les gars ça
tu vois c'est un coût qui peut être dans
un court ça ça peut être dans un court
ce coupé 5
allez on prend une photo on l'envoie sur
twitter la le bessin qu'il est vraiment
beau sata ça tu vois dans un court ça
peut être un super truc
ouais alors tu peux faire tour à sept
mais du coup au pire un au pire j'ai
obtenu le bénéfice de la structure c'est
à dire que là j'ai une structure de jeu
j'ai même pas le mot quoi et b5 je me
débarrasse des pions doublé isolé et je
m'en prends au lion pas de verse b5 ça
c'est un coup que j'aime ça ça fait
plaisir
vous vous sentez à quel point c'est un
coût qui changent le cours de la game ou
pas mais ce que vous le sentez allez le
chat est ce que le chat sans quelque
chose est ce que c'est ce que le chat
est bon faudra inverser les calmer en
fait le truc c'est que sinon on va
passer notre vie à inverser inversée
inverser les échiquiers et ça peut être
un poil relou on va rester cotée blanc
en fait on a fait le truc rouve 1 2 3
on a fait le truc de tourner moi ça me
donne le tournis en fait à force de
regarder côté blanc côté noir côté blanc
j'ai du mal à me concentrer
alors je sais pas vous mais on sait que
s'éveille schalit qui allaient blancois
mais du coup le coup b5 vous sentez ma
puissance vraiment vous sentez pas la
puissance du coup b5 vous le sentez pas
le le à quel point c'est un game center
à quel point tu fais genre h3 tour des
huit tu es mal parce que tu as ton taton
pions faible à vis et comment la petite
opportunités tactiques sur b5 c'est les
noirs qui vont avoir des pions faible
vous le sentez pas ça parce que ça ça
franchement si vous commencez à sentir
ce genre de choses ça va vous faire
passer un gap 1 franchement ça fait
passer un gap la de sentir la puissance
d'un coup comme b5 le chat cesser ça
change tout en fait au lieu d'avoir toi
les deux pions faible c'est les noirs
qui sont les pions faible c'est vraiment
la partie tourne avec ce coup quoi
et maintenant peut-être du cavalier à
quatre cavaliers ses seins qu'on fixe
les faiblesses on mange on se décale on
pique
non mais du coup à licha le fait que
vous n'avez pas joué b5 peut-être pour
un point de vue tactique ça c'est
possible parce qu'il fallait voir un peu
la tactique et ce n'était pas simple
mais le fait de sentir que
stratégiquement c'est un game challenger
mais prendre mais c'était pas possible
ce que j'ai montré si sûr bessin konsa
apprend il y avait tout reprend tout
reprend déviation de la tour et ont
bouffé le cavalier fantastique et si
elle prenait 2 c on bouffait le pion
bessette
mais on avait besoin de le jouer
maintenant parce que si on joue un autre
coup tour à des 8 et c'était fini on
avait plus de b 5 ans avait les pions
doublé à vie pour j'insiste un peu un
jeu fait un peu le rôle ou avec ce truc
là mais parce que c'est hyper important
les gars c'est primordial de comprendre
ça c'est primordial les amis et là un
coup que j'ai pas du tout aimé de la
part de baixa lycée c'est fou prend ses
six fours en c6 je n'ai pas du tout aimé
ce pion il est mauvais à vis tes change
ta meilleure pièce la tech en échange le
patron du game vlad juniors ça j'aime
pas du tout moi elle est un pion plus
maintenant qu'à la fin d'une variante
mais du coup le pion b2 il va pas
avancer
j'ai pas aimé les amis la russe n'avait
pas vu non plus b5
c'était peut-être peut-être 3,4 qu avant
il fallait déjà prévoir qui et b5 et ce
n'était pas facile quoi c'est tombé au
nom tout reprend à 4 non non c'est une
pièce en un c'est une pièce en un mot
c'est incroyable de pas avoir ça c'est
incroyable de ne pas avoir des pièces en
un c'est un peu le vent va dire le point
faible de ce tournoi c'est un peu un peu
voilà ce qui est un peu gâchée parfois
certaines parties dans ce tournoi c'est
c'est les pièces données en un an il y
en a eu un peu trop
j'ai pas ce que vous en pensez mais a
quand même eu beaucoup de pièces en un
coin une classe attaque et bim tu la
protèges c'est c'est dommage si là
encore c'est une belle partie mais une
pièce donnée en impasse que sur tours
pour 1,80 m et c'est ce qui gâche un peu
certaines parties parfois des cadeaux en
asie' vanina et en finale mais là c'est
la finale pour la petite finale pour la
troisième place
mais j'ai quand même mis la finale dans
le titre parce que sinon on s'en sort
pas alors ça ça peut faire nul parce
qu'en fait le fou y tient il tient ça et
je pense que ça va être nul ça peut
faire nul il va falloir voir si un zouk
gang
le roi va venir en e2 ça c'est sûr après
moi je serai amené le fond ou 3 et
j'aurais mis le pion en b 6 quand j'en
avais l'occasion avec les blancs parce
que j'ai l'impression que le pion en v6
peut être un jour dans certaines
variantes il fait b 7 bis et 8
je pense c'est une forteresse mais ouais
c'est la petite finale
la faire 3 1 pouces et 5
le problème c'est qu'il ya roigé un roi
g2 il n'y a pas de zoom grand angle ça
doit être nul ça est une forteresse mais
elle va la faire tomber
fait plutôt roi g13 j'ai deux petites
ces chaussées temps d'accès allez salut
à leur tige et c'est ces deux génies
alors qu singh doit être j'ai mis mes
baixa line on va essayer wgm donc elle
doit elle est moins forte salut cyril
off
bon peut-être fut roi j'ai à faire gaffe
à roye des 5
elle a voulu tuer le pré vraiment là
kosteniuk qui fait du très très sale
parce qu'elle sait que c'est nul il joue
juste la pendule un as et tsahal
là c'est sale elle sait que c'est nul
elle a aucune idée de gains et elle veut
faire tomber vaishali qu'eva joly qui va
pouvoir près vous fous ces cinq ici il
va y avoir un f4 qui va lui tomber
dessus
ouais c'est bien joué elle va la faire
tomber
bah ouais c'est très sale là encore
c'est le jeu ma pauvre lucette mais bon
franchement c'est très moche et
maintenant il ya trois c4
c'est le jeu ma pauvre lucette bon il
faut mettre le roi eux deux mais ça va
perdre après roy c3 faire food et de
fouet trois balles schalit qui peut
améliorer ans aurait perdu de façon
ouais c'est moche
c'est le jeu ma pauvre lucette très
sèchement ses consignes ukiah les blancs
ce fameux stein carottes ouais bon c'est
comme ça après un pas beau mais du coup
ça rend la partie assez moche placé
dommages et une baie saint qui est
intéressant
c'est un peu dommage quoi que sa
première partie je joue quand même lancé
une vente de l'espagnol sas est tous
assez théorique on avait vu des parties
de mvl là dessus je pense avec les
blancs contre aronian mais je peux dire
une bêtise je pense que vaille charlie
va être dans le dur non mais après si la
partie avait été propres de la part de
kosteniuk gagner comme ça grâce au temps
ça aurait été sympa mais là en fait on
voit une partie serrée malgré une pièce
donnée en un mois c'est quand même ce
terrible terrible
bon là ça va faire deux r1 je vous
annonce deux heures la fête la position
un peu pénible ce que si bon on va on va
regarder juste ça attendez je vais
mettre la position bien on voit que le
fou b3 est super fort sur cette
diagonale le fou j'ai 6 8 ans emmurées
dans les pions blancs et le fouet f6 il
a un peu de thym genre même même si on
faisait ça genre pont pour bien
visualiser regarder concrètement la
différence entre le fou dessin qui est
censé être le mauvais fou mais qui est
dominant et le fou g6 qui tape dans
l'oeil ont là il ya aussi la colonne a
maintenant qui s'est ouverte donc il ya
toujours à 7 qui arrive damas tête j'ai
4 ans premier histoire de plus avoir le
clouage l'on peut se permettre parce que
le roi peut pas se faire attaquer tour à
sept et ça fait mal non la weiss ali ag
quatre là je pense important je pense
que tu veux pas laisser f 5 ans elle
sait jouer tu veux pas laisser f5
libérateur et maintenant cavalier des de
f4 f5 à la sa ronde comme dans du beurre
les frérots la cave et l'idée de f4 f5
ses champs mais ça fait très mal un
cahier dé de f4 f5 ça fait très très mal
non enragé 2 c'était peut-être
ouais c'est utile comme coup alors la
baixa lice fait prendre dans l'ouverture
vaishali weichs à lyon sueur un alba
elle va prendre le tarot à chagny
vaishali va prendre tarot les amis f6
bien joué mais peut-être un an cavaliers
h4 du coup va vers l'avant va vers
l'avant et tués
tu touche f5 va italien en difficulté un
ça va faire très très mal à valley avec
un relief ça c'est terrible
regardez la différence entre le cavalier
à 5 et le fouet cette vous la voyez vous
la voyez pas le chat voit cette
différence ou pas est-ce que le tchad
voit la différence entre weichs ali ici
et entre le cavalier f5 et regarder la
tour qui arrive en e1 d'amd de d'un f4
ces gamins c'est game has a fait il ya
même du tout réussi ce qui peut être
autour de 6 à tour aux six peut-être au
ça fait mal aux la tour prend pions
prend le pion eux qui passent olala
c'est une horreur peut-être tu vas
devoir jouer g6 ici pour mais tu vas tu
as fait bien encore plus mais peut-être
g6 tu dois faire avec ériger trois la
dame qui arrive en e2 ça va être game ça
c'est pas bon les gars elle prend 1,8 ok
je suis un peu étonné de cette prise en
voilà pas là revient veille chilien elle
est vraiment sous pression elle est
vraiment sous pression
ouais les tours sont trop fort mais je
vous avais dit kosteniuk était
dangereuse et que du coup moi aussi
j'étais très dangereux pour ce tournoi
je serais très très dangereux pour ce
tournoi le tournoi en danger mais
kosteniuk que normalement elle est
vraiment forte ans elle fait mal un
bavard est en or qui avaient lieu 4 et
sur dame prend il ya tout reproche cet
échec roi prend h7 cavalli f6 terrifiant
terreïs ou quatre ça fait mal un bon
allez elle va faire tout rouge et 7 faut
résister un peu un prouver que tu
existes 1 dames 4c pleutres mais bon
dame prend 1,4 qui apprend à quatre bras
c'est tellement cata t'as déjà vu contre
une des deux jeunes comme j ai je veux
beaucoup de partis sur une chaise comme
contre contre kosteniuk et je crois que
j'ai plus 6 ou +7 1 j'ai un bon score
j'ai un bon score grâce aux conseils de
vlad qui a déjà joué pas mal de parties
contre elle et qui m'avait expliqué les
points forts et les points faibles du
coup quand tu as les conseils delgrande
des villes a dit oh ça fait très mal
entre 8 à 4 je pense tu force les
changes et tu fait très mal
ce terrible irrite input probabilité de
te voir beats est aujourd'hui possible
un peu plus tard mais on va avoir pas
mal de choses aujourd'hui donc me voir
bien blitz et non me voir blitz et
peut-être par un chauffard dont il
pourra échanger 1 8 point avec moi non
plus je joue aux sox ok là y'a plein de
gains mais y'a genre juste pour preuve
cette déjà cavalli m6 qui a valu aux
huit suffit je pense que je serais parti
pour sa logique m'attend prochaine
masque à deux prochaines master class de
vlad rodolphe mer mercredi
mercredi 1er juillet on commence le mois
bien on veut encourager asad sayeed
terrible pays qui va venir aussi c'est
fini un cc games puis passe elle va la
jouer fine schalit 6 à 3 r direct est ce
que cela te connais bien cost et du coup
il connaît pas mal mais il m'avait dit
en fait si tu joues un truc technique où
il n'ya pas tactique pas la face sur le
roi tu gagnes facile et il a raison dès
qu'il ya de la tactique que s'attaque le
roi et où elle est impressionnante elle
est hyper dangereuse et les arnaquer les
voit très vite
par contre ouais c'est game lacaille
prend b5 qui a valu à trois cavaliers c4
et tu pousses des deux côtés c'est game
c'est game de chez games heures tu peux
même faire si jamais tu as peur qui a et
b cinq cavaliers la nb4 tu feras un mur
pour le roi
avec la fin du confiant je préférerais
plus de stream bitstream le week end que
pendant la semaine perso il ya des
stream tout le temps cela est la taupe
il ya eu stream lundi mardi mercredi
jeudi vendredi je crois qu'il ya eu 50
heures de stream à peu près peut-être un
peu moins peut-être 40 et calque 7 42 43
et aelia s'il n'y a pas eu ce tri
milliards et à stream aujourd'hui il va
y avoir stream de 14,30 au final à 20
2h30 23 heures vendredi soir n'y a pas
eu stream est extrêmement drôle
d'histoire
c'est pas vrai fake news info chat
bon ça fait deux heures alors que
scénique très très dangereuse tu peux
pas à jouer des positions tactiques
comme ça contre elles ou à l attaque
tu peux pas te permettre ce rendez vous
compte les pieds ouais tu peux pas te
permettre de la laisser attaquer ouais
ça la taupe qui nous envoient des fêtes
newsin
la taille des échos
non il est beaucoup de frime cette
semaine et pas beaucoup de sable sur
bitstream d'ailleurs les gars le gars
qui se plaint déjà ça y est non mais
j'ai vu que les trois bras est à 8000
sable je me dis on fait les mêmes
audiences faut que je montre l'objectif
faut qu'il faut que je montre l'objectif
n'a en vrai ça ralentit un peu non sans
rigoler mais c'est pas grave mais quand
même je vous incite à sable parce que tu
vois je suis encore bâtard aussi tu vois
on parie vinsobres je suis pas si
violent pareils et 30 on en pareille 30
à les commandes vont pas marché la libye
well et chassera ils ont huit cas
s'habitue à ils font les mêmes audiences
que nous ils ont eu qu à sable j'ai
envie de te dire je pensais qu'à 1500
seube
on était très très beau et très très
haut maintenant je me dis peut-être
qu'on va être plus de musique techno
faire moins de master class
j'étais juste pas content hier soir
épicé tous à l'atome est un peu regardé
le live
gt gt vu moi je t'ai vu le sly la taupe
en vrai vendredi soir vendredi soir
après mon live
je t'ai vu sur le live d'un certain
absolument un qui parlait dé
cosplayeuses tu étais dans le chat on te
voit cela est la taupe
ça parle ça parle de cosplayeuses cela
il a topé l'a1 voilà un faut le savoir
c'est pas moi qui le dit ce pot todd
spots hadas la taupe qui n'écrit plus
dans le châtain voilà nous t'avons vu le
niveau de sueur de sly la taupe là il
est en train de s'essuyer il est en
trahi leur entrain de cécile et le front
c'est game pour sly la top c'est game
c'est game c'est à dire que tu étais
aussi moi je suis passé voir le poteau
absolue à la fin et j'ai vu que j'ai vu
pas mal de messages dans le chatt 1
c'était c'est un des plus actifs faut le
savoir
faut le savoir il s'échine à froid et
que vous faire du charpentier
bon alors cette partie j'ai l'impression
que le le combat au centre en train de
super bien se placer pour les noirs
parce que le fou être monstrueux après
est-ce qu'on va réussir à pousser avec
les majors g5 f4 pour être une idée
peut-être en faut que les blancs ils
réussissent à ouvrir la haye que f et c
c'est chaud
on à villevieux ans il est marrant
finalement ce match pour la 3e place et
ses shows la game et le front g7 fait
peur parce qu'il brille quand même mais
peut-être le roi fait peur avec des
oeufs est fait des détours qui viennent
à eux un des dames en russie ce ses
shows donna est quand même
c'est chaud de knight mais je pense tu
dois faire f quoique fois oui je rêve
comme tout reprend et je mettrai une
touriste y jouer un peu la colonne
essayer de dire que le roi est faible
ça me paraîtrait le plus logique en fait
cela est la taupe qui s'appelle harry
gow l'est beaucoup plus les niveaux de
la blague mais moi ça me fait peur donc
ils n'arrivent pas à venir colonnes
enfin n'arrive pas à venir coloniaux
mais maintenant est ce qu est ce que
dame prend tour à
bon peut-être elle peut prendre f1
annoncé l'échec ou prendre prendre je
suis perdu dans mes pensées
et ça ça vaut quoi comme finale
wes peut être pénible ouais c'est pas ça
joue plus sur la tactique que la
stratégie en fait ces variantes
bon mais la forêt c'est pas bête ce
qu'avait dames 3 elle sait bien jouer
parce qu'elle veut affaiblir b2 elle
fait ça pour s'en prendre à b2 et du
coup elle doit avoir une variante un peu
comme ça non pas de la tour f 4 là ce
serait grave
mais tous rêvent 5 qui ont f5 b3 ouais
mais pour moi les noirs et les noirs
sont pas mieux et je la joue avec les
blancs tour eiffe inquiets et des 1
j'essaye de me gilbert structure de
pions quand même avec les blancs j'ai
deux îlots à la 4e' l'eau
ok je bouffe rreef 5 et je ferai b3 faut
que tu as un os depuis tâche est à l'os
mais à l'osm à sean may chanet lost mais
juste sur ce tournoi et en plus on n'est
pas sur ma chaîne perso il y aura il y
aura jamais beaucoup de monde c'est
impossible qu'ils aient beaucoup de
monde qui suivent ce tournoi
regardez en espagnol aujourd'hui sont
que 99 alors qu'ils étaient 250 300
avant nous on était cinq sens les autres
jours on et 220 aujourd'hui donc aussi
parfois les compteurs twitch marche
moins bien
parfois les compteurs twitch y compte
pas exactement le nombre de viewer c'est
une catastrophe en portugais ils sont
mais c'est pas dit que ce soit les vrais
chiffres en vrai et les allemands ils
sont 174 on sait pas pourquoi mais assez
parfois twitch en fait il ça arrive que
les compteurs soit 10 ça arrive qu'ils
soient faux est-ce qui donc je pense je
vois pas pourquoi on serait moins
aujourd'hui mais je veux dire par là que
moi je compare souvent plus avec les
autres langues
au même moment parce que c'est plus les
américains ils étaient sept huit mille
îles sont 4300 donc je préfère comparer
avec les autres chaînes twitch à titre
perso parce que tu peux avoir
tu peux avoir des compteurs qui marche
qui marchent pas à certains jours direct
j'aurai toujours des master class de
matthew moment donné on s'est retrouvé à
45 10 minutes après on était sept sans
fin il ya des
il sait bien jouer b3 parce que sky
prend les atours f3 probablement tour 8
qui a validé un celi des médias f4
encore fou prend pas l'idée fou prend
tout reprend à ok ça c'est la pointe ça
tu peux le prendre facilement avec les
blancs à la fée tourcoing f5 je pensais
qu'elle veut essayer de jouer le truc
oui c'est bien mieux tout rond et
sinclair mais touré vite je pensais
qu'elle veut essayer de jouer le gain de
pièces ça marchait pas et f4 fouquereau
f4 ça pouvait être une pointe à ces
salles est ce que tu sais ce qu'on va
faire la deuxième plus grosse chaîne de
chess comme à
dur à dire chaises comme espagnol chasse
comme espagnol est peut-être plus gros
que chess com/fr sur twitter par contre
je peux te dire que blitz stream est la
plus grosse chaîne étrangère échec au
monde sur twitter ça c'est sûr et
d'assez loin en fait même de très loin
donc elle est là c'est quoi le cavalier
cinq tours g3 et ça va mais mon kg si ça
peut être dangereux et les tours 1 qui
rhodia ça il ya beaucoup de choses
attaquer là que ça sent pas très bon
pour aïcha les cavaliers eu cinq
attaques la tour tour j'ai trois forces
et cavaliers j'ai ici c'est on semble
dynamiquement
flash 4 sous pressions menaces ou prend
ces trois cavaliers pros h4 du coup pour
des clous et il ya toujours eu un fou g1
qui menace la fouée f2 qui menacent ya
beaucoup de menaces là si elle fait ça
je pense c'est game mais l'a pas fait à
la fait cavalier c'est un orteil c1
c'est très bizarre comme coup parce que
lecavalier ici pas au lieu de revenir
vers le centre et de revenir là où il
est bien il par un peu il par un peu bon
c'est tant mieux pour le match non
anglophones tu veux dire oui étrangers
du truc qui arriverait mais du coup wavy
étrangers puisque c'est pour thiès comme
étrangers pour te laisse comme nom et
étrangers de la halle enfin non
anglophones et c'est sûr que c'est le
j'avais un poil regarderai les calmes
vraiment là elle est bien cadré par
rapport à la camca là il va essayer un
peu mieux la cadre elle c'est un poil
baissé
pendant que je regarderai les canines
cas comment elle a perdu comment
kosteniuk a perdu une qualité là à temps
il ya encore une gaffe c'est quoi ce
bordel
mais quoi les cavaliers c'est un qui
était mal placé et tour g1 qui est des
cinq ok c'est six cavaliers 7
ah oui et du coup et si tu fais trois
sets ya fouache quatre échecs et faut
prendre
ouais non mais bon c'est dommage
c'est sûr c'est la fiara c'est la finale
pour la troisième place pour le moment
mais je savais pas qu'il avait une
finale pour elle va tenter à 4 de base
pour la troisième place et cela qu'elle
est forte kosteniuk mais sur ces trois
rois prend ses deux tours f1 le pion est
bloqué ok roy e st croix des quatre il
ya le pion qui arrive en d2 mais il y
aura jamais de ces trois français
les caïds et de l art tenter un piège
bon là je pense le plus simple c'était
de jouer tour f 4 à 3 4 ans et quatre
non mais oui là elle joue très bien
aller c'est bien failli schalit qui va
égaliser 20 qui va égaliser qui va
revenir au score et qui va tourner et du
coup à deux allez c'est sympa pour le
match là que ces nus karaté une vraie
balle de 3 0
mais normalement je pense que c'était la
dernière ouais c'était la dernière
session
cailloux qu'ils y compris les hausses
moyennes on glisse ring c'est vraiment
la première chaîne or or anglais sur
twitch de trélon devant les russes
devant tout le monde
même devant des espagnols qui ont des
premières pages trois fois par semaine
la chaîne de rosé rrh pas qu'on me fie à
tout du tout en première page
mais même même que sa vraie et de loin
en plus vraiment un écart important par
faut le savoir ouais c'est pas moi qui
le dit
et ce soir ya le seul battle mais il
faut me suivre sur twitter les
mannequins vous me suivez pas sur
twitter
mais là par exemple le chat qui a je
pense qu'il ya plus de gens que qui
écrit sur sur le stream la cadence la
prochaine can en c3 +1 après ce sera un
plus un j'aime bien le un plus un perso
j'aime bien
ses premières passes quand philippe
rapacz s'est pris un patch twitch
premières pages switch ce qui amène
beaucoup de monde
déjà retoqué les seuls qui combattent ce
sera à 20h bout du rouleau et le match
sera à 20h30 contre les pieds par contre
les bras favé sur tik tok cachait pas
qu'il est allé sur tik tok moi j'ai
ouvert tik tok une fois mais ça me fait
peur
les deux sont alors exactement en même
temps raymond caresse mon cas s mais bon
faut qu'ils revoient un peu la valeur
complète le truc de team france avoir un
truc un peu plus à ce qu'un effectuant
neuf cent soixante ans machin contre les
mêmes équipes
ouais contre les bras je pense qu'on va
reprendre le tarot as tu veux dire ce
tic toc la vrt que j'ai fait joyent made
fable sortie stocks mais après pourquoi
pas un petit truc marrant à faire
donc
ouais on saurait qui leur semble à fond
et j'ai compris elle est fantastique la
vidéo mur facile pour être sûr tik tok
du lait vidéo blizzard qui fait
du coup 2 1 c'est chaud kosteniuk bien
devant mais bon c'est jamais envahie
schalit va et shalit qui est là bas il
ya ba qui dans le chat on renvoie bas
qui bâtit qui vient apprendre les échecs
là sur ce match baky qui est chaud bah
c'est en quoi tu voir le chat huant les
pseudo tu as bâti des chocolats
concurrents baky dans le chat un baky
sauvage qui apparaît alors l'argent va
chauffer bas qui va écrire elle va
utiliser labaki droite alain duault été
sabotés passa par cette chaîne rouve en
2 3 tu es sabah la chaîne bitstream des
passeurs à la chaîne chez ascom france
c'est pour ça j'ai prévu quoi comme
motivation la vidéo de motivation elle
va être marrant de ce soir là il paraît
qu'il ya mia aussi qui s'est mis à fond
sur sur tik tok a voilà mvele enfin là
en vrai c'est pas la finale c'est la
petite finale c'est la petite finale
en fait on avait envoyé un emploi du
temps qui disait que le dimanche il y
aurait 90 minutes de stream cesser pour
que moi je puisse tu vois m'ajuster par
rapport à ce que je dois faire donc je
dis 90 minutes de stream comme on en
voyait ça on m'envoyait de ces les
horaires ben moi je me fais mes horaires
de la semaine et on me dit bah du coup
c'est 14h30 16h le stream aujourd'hui
donc moi je me dis ça veut dire qu'il
n'ya que qu'il ya qu' une finale tu vois
ce que je veux dire c'est un chat et
intuitif quoi et après tout d'un coup je
me connecte et je vois weichs ali contre
kosteniuk je me dis mais chalier
kosteniuk elles ont été éliminées et du
cou et du coup en fait j'étais autant
autant autant surpris que vous en faites
quand vous êtes arrivé j'étais j'ai
ouvert le truc des caméras filment et à
temps mais veillent schalit va échalier
à l'april tarot kosteniuk elle a pris
part où il se passe quoi et pas ce qui
nous fait du rab
ouais ouais enfin
on en parlera avec french à la fin du
larivot je te le dis tout de suite ça va
bien se passer
et merci a dit commagnac pour pour le
raid merci tonton merci dicko merci
maniaque
merci du come and iraq du coup qu'ils
nous envoient 33 personnes ça fait
plaisir ça bienvenue à tout du coup vous
allez pouvoir suivre le deuxième
deuxième partie de match on suit donc le
match pour la troisième place entre
alexandra kosteniuk la joueuse russe et
vice à li joueuses jeune joueuse
indienne coaching qui avec championne du
monde et qui a une manucure noires et
blanches assalama d'un en russie et les
filles aiment bien faire manucure avec
les ongles de deux couleurs ma femme le
fait de temps en temps c'est pas mal
mais après je sais pas si c'est la mode
partout je suis pas forcément au fait de
la mode a fondé la manucure mai mais du
coup sa fatwa je comprends que c'est ça
la mode
ouais non je comprends que ça la mode en
fait ce que je vois ma femme le faire de
temps en temps il faudrait qu'on
l'appelle l'experte l'experte mode là on
serait on serait bien que là je suis mal
l'a déjà en tee shirt eu mal elle m'a
dit faut arrêter les t-shirts que des
chemises c est qu sécu décès quoique des
chemises que des chemises que des
chemises quoi bon allez c'est reparti
weichs ali j'attends le nom d'aïcha lit
ça me fait marrer ce genre de jeu serait
j'adore ce rallye ça donne envie d'être
pour elle
un stream beauté maquillage est pourquoi
pas un problème docteur docteur jules
lucky qui est sur le chat qui paie pont
qui paie pont et ya une fois merci pour
la qualité de tes tutoriel etienne
bacrot voilà n'hésitent pas à acheter
chic ye brave à rejouer ce truc là et je
pense que si maxime s'est tu avais pas
joué une partie contre les vols dans
cette variante genre en coupe du monde
est avait gagné avec les blancs
s'étaient pas genre genre t'as partie et
a dû faire des nuls aussi non c'est doré
feu
je laisse avec les vins et même avec les
norvège et lui parles de tes parties
mettant avait gagné une belle non contre
les bonnes en coupe du monde
vous savez pousser les pions affronte
avait dominé voit le coach et sur le
chat mais le coach le coach répond pas
il salue plus crew tie break mais c'est
n'est pas facile je me rappelle tact un
tie-break mythique d'ailleurs qui avait
mal tourné au final qui s'était joué à
l'armageddon mais le sait ça c'est un
tie break assez connue j'ai envie de
dire ouais t'as jamais obtenir cette
position et dameuse faut faire super
gaffe de passe prendre un cavalier f4
h33 f3 mais pour le moment tu peux
mettre la dame henri iv donc ça va je
passe je joue pas tout réussi avec les
noirs et touré fuite je vais pas leur
dire huit toiles schiste ou réfutent
cavaliers f4 qui est prêt h 3
moi j'aime bien les noirs là mais c'est
être un effet d'optique ski à la case ou
abba qui avait 4 1 3 est bloqué pour
dimitri ne suivent pas la chaîne battant
on va on va on va lui ouvrir le chat à
temps
vas-y peut écrire il peut écrire
batterie civ il ya plus dix minutes à
attendre
j'ai débloqué bas qui bat qui est libre
c'est marrant quand il décrira evans il
n'y a pas un tour f
ton geste est fort ce que dit le redis
cahier f4 mais pour protéger tous rêvent
5 c'était le premier truc mais y'avait
dames 3e 6 échecs et la cavale et f4 res
et c'est bien que la faim tue et à ce
tour f 5 quand même double attaque
ouais c'est chaud chaud de knight
bakkies jouets analysés l'ouverture
enfin tu es là bas qui bâtit bas qui est
là quoi ça y est on revit qu'on lit doit
lever le bar bug nam en gros les
candidats ça pourrait reprendre en
septembre octobre
pour faire simple allez peut-être tour
f5 d'un mec ça va être chaud montour f5
façon bien quoi d'autre quoique tu
investissent aussi à tanger si ce que
tous rêvent 5 g des six peut-être ton
j'y suis têtu garde un oeil là-dessus
t'attaques là ouais je serais parti pour
tourner ici ce perso mais ils disent ils
disent même pas il fait un suspens qui
dit qu'il est même pas sûr que ça
reprenne je parte je serais parti
contrôle est même pas sûr et là
peut-être d'am-dam pas il est même adam
bessède pas mal sa courte cavale et oued
a mis 8 aussi j'aime bien un bail qui
arrive à gagner celle-là elle va aller
at akkaf kg 3 bien joué et tu retour des
cinq dames prend 1,6 et le cavalier bloc
bien prêt non stop stick xc c'est même
pas sûr que ça reprenne en russie ça
même pas dans quelle ville ça reprend
enfin c'est bizarre
non mais c'est ça va être bizarre comme
tournoi parce que le fait l'épidémie
elle disparaît à certains endroits elle
reprend à d'autres c'est un peu spécial
je pense que personnellement je pense
qu'il faudrait faire c'est un match
entre néo peau et mvl en huit parties et
décider du candidat comme ça en fait je
pense c'est la meilleure solution
j'ai six tours 4 tours f5 et c'est bien
joué il n'y a pas de problème 5 adam
pranger de maths elle va prendre des
cinq à mon avis elle va elle va demander
au noir de trouver une manière
d'attaquer ce que dame prend b5 après tu
envoies le pion et tu demandes aux noirs
de trouver une attaque rien dire c'est
intéressant est ce que ce truc là est
dangereux pour moi ça me terrifie parce
que je suis peut être mais pascal tout
reprend jitrois d'un projet 3 quoi et si
je fais ça bon ça me fait peur mais au
final tu remets la ddt
ouais mesdames f7 je sais pas elle a
fait d'amd 6 je pensais qu'elle
boufferez b5
tours ff6 dont clairement ça fait peur
mais en vrai est ce qu'il ya des menaces
peut-être b 3 à 4 et envoie le recul
j'aurais été tellement tenté juste
d'envoyer les pions pour alexandra
j'arrive pas avoir de menace pour les
noirs on revient aux cadres de toute
façon là on 17
le 4g mais bien parce que tu te mets au
k4 j'adore et humer à sky prend un f5
d'ailleurs moral en plus ces clous et et
g3 réel a bien joué alexandra roy jeu et
à damas trois dames g4 le retour d'un
machin waouh c'est pas vraiment un coup
intuitif pour moi mais c'est elle se
débrouille bien et puis on prend 1,5 là
ça fait mal en point f1 dame pranger 6e
tour point f1 c'est le tarot et la
reprise prises et un petit coup de
tourbe et inquiets des quatre qui a
hissé de il ya un pion passé le pion qui
avance mais maintenant des 4 et la tour
qui bloque tout c'est fini elle va
ramener le roi il va faire tout reprend
ses deux c'est bien joué à petit piège
donc on sait qu'il prend des quatre il
est vu et ça fait 3
voilà elle a fait un peu n'importe quoi
non mais tu restreint la compet année
peau et mvl pour les candidats donc
c'est un genre d'ouest un diane
contraint réty et on voit les noirs qui
sont mis en position baky avec le petit
fou en baisse est là je pense qu'on peut
reprendre du pied aux sinon la demande
et à max et syfy qui est dans le chat
mais je pense reprendre du plomb c'est
possible non pour jouer ces 5 et jouer à
la ba qui un peu comme dans sa partie au
numéro 1 contre maso pour ceux qui ont
suivi le match d'entraînement ça aucun
sens pas prêt pas mais je pense était
possible de rejouer un peu pareil non
ma proposition aucun sens ouais mais je
m'en fous bah voila moi je fais comme
vous alors come back il propose direct
mvl magnus non mais ça me paraît logique
en fait ça me paraît bien bikey à ses
sens et comme personne toujours écouté
baky dans un chat je pense faut toujours
écouter un bas qui dans un chat serait
bon en fait maxime qui vient aux
candidats sans se qualifier ils gagnent
les candidats sont les terminée et il
devient champion du monde sur un corps
aux navires us pour pour mag liffe us
quoi ce serait extraordinaire pas le mec
qui tient le champion du monde ce serait
beau téva championship ont été aux
quatre tournois quoi chaque fois
l'évêque tombent comme des mouches quoi
tous les tous ses adversaires sont
corogne ses adversaires sont corogne les
uns après les autres ce serait beau quoi
se réjouir avec la meilleure immunité
qui reporte qui remporte le coup serait
extraordinaire quoi maxime champion du
monde par résistance
très extraordinaire sélection naturelle
à chaque sélection naturelle mvl
champion du monde
alors cette position voilà pas voulu la
jouer là bas qu'ici en reprenant 2 e
elle se retrouve un peu mal il ya de la
pression sur la colonne des elle n'a pas
fini le développement il va falloir
réussir à sortir si elle avait la tour
ensuite je pense ça irait mais il ya la
tour en 1 8
man ouest et le patinage de vitesse ou
le mec avait gagné sur chute
il avait réussi à gagner puisque c'était
le plus nul ils n'étaient jamais dans le
peloton de tête et les mecs tomber les
uns après les autres c'était
extraordinaire le mec était super landes
quoi ça c'est beau quand même il devait
même pas se qualifier qu'on était
vraiment complètement extraordinaire
rester un australien le mec n'a aucun
rapport avec le sport en fait c'était du
short track ouais je pense il était très
très loin en demi en finale n'était pas
du tout dans le groupe de tête
bon ça reste toujours un poil
désagréable si les tours c'est cette qui
arrive à lecavalier à 4 un peu loin mais
bon il ya des tournées un échec en
contrepartie france la taupe qui revient
dans le chatt quoi cela top qui revient
en secrète jean ries s'est rien passé
la top qui va plus jamais osé parler
dans aucun chat du tweet game quoi cette
fantastique on t'a vu sur la chaîne de
sasha grey l'autre soir cela tôt dans le
chat ça c'était pas vrai sur les
cosplayers c'était vrai mais ça c'était
pas vrai ça c'est favre on est dimanche
des gants peut se permettre on peut se
permettre et la table tous les gars
d'antan le chat qui sont en train de
chercher sur google twitch sasha grey
pour voir s'il ya vraiment une chaîne
twitch donc non mais là ça doit aller
pour les noirs maintenant pourquoi je
suis d'humeur taquine haut puisque c'est
dimanche aprèm et qu'hier j'ai rien
foutu j'ai dormi j'étais à la place je
suis allé faire un resto et tout donc
fuir je suis d'humeur espiègle
bon cavalier aux cinq qui vient est
retour qui va venir ans et 7
et puis enfin pas trop chaud aujourd'hui
fait un peu moins chaud si les audiences
étaient un peu abattus par la chaleur
tour 17 comme ça
mon fils que lecavalier a des problèmes
à revenir qui allie noir un peu en sueur
le cavalier blanc qui équivaut lui aussi
partir sur la huitième ils sont heureux
les cavaliers elle joue pas mal la baixa
lui je crois
ouache 7 à voir remettre le cavalier ans
et six bien ce qu'elle fait je crois
les cavaliers des huit attaques la tour
à tour 17
calais prend 1,6 à haypro 2 akaïev et
échec à sa santé qu'il y avait un truc
dans les pièces noires et maintenant
qu'ils avaient à cavalli a fui 3g 8 à
temps comme on fait ça cavalier g63 h7
pourra g8 forcément ça perd une pièce
qui est g63 cette force et f4 mais
pourquoi tu fais ça à l vf5 qui avait
allégé si ces tourets fuite mat 1
c'était pas si con mais la main il ya
cavalier a accueilli g63 h7 toujours
talent à katia kameli prend le 4tet g4
elle fâche 4 attend là ils menacent plus
rien h5 cavalli g6 le roi pourra partir
en f 7 s'était pas extraordinaire ce
qu'elle a fait il va y avoir un tour d2
elle va se faire contrer bon
la sara et maintenant tour d2 elle prend
près le prend pourquoi tu fais ça il n'y
avait pas de menace non pour les blancs
tous réfutent y avait juste 3 6 j'ai pas
compris le bail
j'ai pas compris maxi par dégoûté par le
coup max qui rage quit quoi j'essaie non
mais moi aussi ça m'a fait mal en fait
c'est fou quoi alors wave 3 qui est
descatoire non ça sent qu'il va y avoir
une fourchette
elles veulent en sueur voilà c'est fini
cette fois ci ouais non c'était fou tout
reprend g6
tu vas aller voter du coup temps mais
c'était fou team accident le tchad
c'était terrible mon voyage à licques et
enfin changer d'espagnol
voilà eu la panique ouais c'est bizarre
elle a dû penser qu'il est toujours en
fuite trois ou six matches bon mais du
coup c'est bien en quelque sorte le
match reste serré on va pas s'en
plaindre hein on va pas s'en plaindre
le niveau de jeu atteint pas des sommets
mais c'est pas grave
bon ça va être marrant il va y avoir des
il va pas y avoir de rock opposés parce
que x h 5 kg 4 elle va faire grand roque
moi j'aime bien les blancs que j'aime
bien je veux la structure la meilleure
structure les pions sont sur blanc ça
joue bien contre le fou de cases
blanches
je pense sur un vrai chic elles sont
plus fortes que moi guilhem
je pense après sur un échiquier 2d comme
chaise comme si ya pas de prépa avant et
qu'elles peuvent pas se préparer contre
ma scandinave normalement comme j'ai
déjà un bon score contre kosteniuk donc
je suis censé être un peu mieux mais si
l on temps de se préparer tout elle même
elle me bat tous les deux parce que du
coup elles vont réfuté mémé ouverture et
je recule chance en vrai les genres
aucune chance ça dépend pas préparés
comme ça à l'arraché
ça va mais c'est en train de se préparer
je me fais défense très clairement
sans aucun doute même sans l'ombre d'un
doute qu'à faire cavalier 3 il est bien
il est bien placé
mais b6 b3 tuer laurent b de moi j'aime
bien les blancs mais jma suroît b 2 ou 3
b un discutable mais j'aurais mis en b2b
en métal problème avec ce pion qui n'est
pas facile à protéger je dois surestimé
les blanches ces genres de position que
j'aime bien jouer ainsi la tour est en
d2 ce serait bien mais bon je serais
tenté de faire tourner deux tours prend
prise tour des huit damev de décès de m
la tour en d1 mais tu peux avoir des
problèmes
jordan f6 ou prend 1,4 ici on a fait h 4
qui je pense est bien joué parce que
maintenant le cavalier peureux bouger
d'un autre côté la tour est bloquée
maintenant qui est en prend d un tour
prend des airs dames 3 4 c'est
clairement un truc à regarder
ok à 4
tata lieu de manger ce pion quand même
ouais ok elle attaque l attaque fort
sastre
je suis créé un autre compte au revoir
château posture à la cfu
la gamme fit des pions h4 elle aurait pu
protéger par g3 à un moment donné
ouais c'est chaud
ces choses c'est juste un pion
maintenant réveil schalit qui va revenir
on va voir
elle est hors des 8,3 bref c'est juste
un pion de plus maintenant il va falloir
le faire fructifier
et vous où huit sa petite focale sur le
cas van dam des six histoires de
proposer les change ça c'est sûr
la topline s'est pas fait clash on a
rigolé avec lui normalement ça devrait
gagner pour les noirs s option h4 qui a
été perdu tout à l'heure il fait mal
parce que maintenant c'est les noirs qui
ont trois contre deux et blanc arrive
pas à créer de menaces le cavalier
complètement embourbé le fou qui va
revenir en c6 je pense parce qu'elle
peut pas faire ça il ya dame prend b5 au
le voit pas non mais ça c'est terrifiant
c'est terrifiant
c'est quand même des pièces en un les
gars heureusement qu'elle veut elle est
partie un ânon il encore là oh le pauvre
ah le pauvre au nom adam prend dame
oh la la
c'est du rhin c'est dur mais visage
cassure
dur mais max sérieusement toi qui
regardent souvent mesrine et qui me
regardent souvent beats avant que tu
pars à tu pars tu joue vraiment aussi
mal que ça parce que ça me fait vraiment
peur de me dire que c'est mon niveau ça
j'ai pas l'impression de faire autant de
gaffes
non sérieux tu me rassures parce que ça
ça va c'est juste ça me ça me déprime de
dire que ça c'est mon niveau quand même
parce que ça c'est quand même des primes
en quoi il y en a quand même beaucoup
mais la partie précédent ne pas avoir
les deux qui va pas d'un prompt b5
d'amsterdam france est un le catch price
et 52 mille balles à la dame prend des
cats ça marche pas parce qu'il ya dame
prend 17
c'est bien joué à l'efo que vaille
schalit reviennent travail maxime qui
m'a réchauffé le coeur
le prêt je vois qu'il ya baky qui
restent dans le château quand même pour
pour affiner la prépa faux faut faire
gaffe quand même on aimerait ça me prend
b6 mais du coup est-ce que c'était works
de commencer par dame des cas là je
pense c'est pas mal joué 52 mille
dollars way le price mais sur quatre
tournois sur quatre semaines
mais en plus on prend un pion prend qu'à
elle et ses 3 5 6 sa chance c'est bien
pour les blancs vraiment cavalia 6 elle
se développe avec ace et 3 s'allume au
22 88
autour des 1 aura cela normalement
vaishali doit égaliser là à l'éveil
schalit
il ya 52 milles en jeu mais se passe 52
minutes pour la gagnante 1 je pense que
si tu gagnes trois grands prix que tu
joues tu as tu prends 9000 et peut-être
pour la finale tu reprends 5000 ou
quelque chose comme ça donc tu dois
pouvoir gagner quatorze ou quinze mille
max frisch ali pas à ces livres d'échec
dr juan
olala docteur jules mais le dimanche
aprèm c'est vraiment les meilleurs qui
sont là bordel olala dr julie il a fait
tellement plaisent là dessus voilà
il faut trois essais bien jouer il va y
avoir des bekkat df4 de sens que ça va
aller
qui dit qu'elle ne triche pas là les
parties peut-être ce le sio plop 1
là je pense que s'il ya des gens qui
accuse de tricher dans dans ce tournoi
là c'est qu'il ya un problème
non là là là clairement il n'y a pas de
triche ça c'est sûr
si sa fraîcheur le vent du site il ise
histoire de le ban dit maxime 1
ça c'est pas mal à ça joue pas mal
ah les fous des quatre saisons magique
en fait je trouve les milieux de jeu
sont assez blé en quoi ça ça joue pas
mal c'est cool
il ya des idées les prépas sont bien et
tout et ça après que ça cracotte un peu
autour des 2 aya pas qualifié ces quatre
là faut être quatre c4 la fois f4 a
laissé bien 16 faut ramener l'euro 1
peut-être y avoue proie aux cinq hauts
et ben voilà allez vas y schalit weichs
ali weichs ali jafari 1,5 vaishali la
vue vers gmail schalit la fête c'est de
tomber aux mains
haweij schalit alors revenir dans le
match aller du coup ça ajoute une partie
voilà c'est terrible c'est terrible
c'est terrible ça jouer pas mal en fait
non mais les ouvertures à la stratégie
c'est bien la tactique c'est pas
terrible mais sinon aux ouvertures et
stratégie c'est plutôt pas mal
je crois que c'était un peu triste
enfin si j'arrive à envie de partir au
contraire au contraire il ya du suspense
tout peut arriver
j'espère une fine meilleure qualité ok
ça a été un peu ça tout le tournoi quand
même c'est qu'à 5/6 game pad branchement
toile pour des erreurs parce qu'au bout
d'un moment si tu t' enthousiaste pas
pour les erreurs tu te tente tous des
asthmes pour rien
tut enthousiasme jamais en fait sinon
c'est à chaque fois dans ces matches là
qu'on a essayé de s'enthousiasmer pour
les bonnes parties se sont toujours
soldées par par des grosses gaffes en a
à la fin donc on va essayer de ce solde
de de ce high pay pour les grosses
gaffes en un honnêtement ça nous chauffe
pour pour les coachings étoiles et
calmes et au tout ça
allez
ah les conviant le chat si les bat 2
seulement je pense en fait je pense y en
a deux qui les battent dans le chatt
salma mais les deux mètres tarot est-ce
que je peux je calme et aux étoiles soir
non
l'étoile qu'un peu joué hier soir du
coup d'après maxime on est censé être
trois à les battre ici
pamela les blancs sont super bien non
mais côté duquel joue bien on devrait
juste à des gaffes mais sinon elle joue
bien là et et prend des quatre cavaliers
f5 et tout
on est on est pas très nombreux pour
cette finale
on n'est pas très nombreux pour cette
petite finale jette un oeil ce qui se
passe dans les autres langues on regarde
un peu de partout un bon là c'est
fantastique parce que le pion des six
est mauvais l'aspect fantastique la
l'aller les blancs sont mes côtés news
dans les ouvertures allait vraiment
forte elle est vraiment largement plus
forte que les autres
il y avait une vraie vraie différence il
ya une vraie vraie vraie différence
il ya une vraie vraie vraie différence
en attendant je vais faire un petit truc
sur l'ordi désolé écrit qu'il y avait un
petit erreur donc la partie qui se
déroule bien pour coter new qui devrait
qui devrait l'emporter sans aucun sans
aucun souci on va voir la fin de la
partie ensemble mais ça devrait à ça
devrait faire game d'ailleurs y'a un
pion qui a été pris quand vous regardez
pas l'écran ou la tour c 8 tours ces
huit tours ces huit tours france et 8
non ça va j'ai l'impression qu'il y
avait une truc qui allait tomber mais ça
a l'air d'aller
on reprend suite d'un français 8 et la
dia peut-être cavalier e set ça forcera
fou prendre cette dame eux prendre cette
liasse a attaqué sa attaquer ouais ça
c'est game non ça c'est game il n'y a
pas de maths en c1 si tu bouges la dame
madame f 8 matchs adam prendre 5 qui
menace c'est game je pense ouais c'est
la part c'est la position de leurs
lacets game là elle est obligée de
donner une pièce damev 7 et un petit
coup de fouet 2 ou h quatre mois
j'aurais fait h4 je pense j'aurais fait
h4 f3
vous ces six bons fous b2 du coup tu te
replaces cette attaque sa dame c4 hockey
bien joué ici dames 8 four b3 voisins et
d'amis
cette juste échange les dames il ya le
temps il ya tout
bref au b2 et c bien h41 finalement faut
y aller un jour allait peut-être un
petit coup d'anne decis maintenant pour
menacer dame prend 1,6 et un petit fou
aussi souhaitons à ces faux f5 et fouet
f5 fou prend m6 c'est game là c'est game
voilà ça fait trois ans allez un
quatrième homme ou la finale avec dame
g6 alors moi j'aurais fait d'alger si je
suis un pleutre j'aurais fait d'amener
si je suis un pleutre
ça joue mieux que labitrie make-up bbox
de très très loin
ouais dame prend et b5 à le faire un
pion passé mais bon tu prends et tu fais
à 6 à 7h 5h énormément tu prends là là
je te prendrai une fois je te ferai à 6
tu vas devoir faire roi sait si ces
chants voile aux deux pions et de toute
façon il ya eu 5 et du bloc c'est la
partie justement les blancs ont gagné
écossais qui mène 5-3 mais qui est
largement au dessus
et ça va être la fin de la cadence donc
grosse domination de kosteniuk est quand
même dans le contenu surveille schalit
grosse domination de kosteniuk surveille
schalit
alors
le break pour chess queen il ya deux
points normalement yade trois ou quatre
parties dans la prochaine cadence on va
voir ce que ça donne raison tous les cas
comme ouverture est beaucoup de bruit
lopez beaucoup d'espagnols des trucs un
peu plus hybride avec les blancs défiant
piéto pour va et xavi
je suis une garde son trône web va
prendre la troisième place elle va
monter sur la petite boîte sûrement je
ne vois pas perdre 3-0 les bullet si
elle en gagne une c'est sûr que c'est
gagné quoique non il peut y avoir quatre
gagnants il y en a trois et peut en
avoir quatre non ça dépend
on va voir ce qu'on peut en pronostics
de baky pour la finale après green in
house chez nina
ça va être chaud le un plus un ça va
être très chaud le un plus un ça va être
bouillant le 3 + 1
voir ce que ça donne mais ça devra être
bouillant bouillantissime la 2e place
pense ya 1500 ou 2000
ça va être chaud le bullet était
avantageux c'est ce qu'une je pense
aussi berly s'emballe ça les plus fortes
elle est forte kosteniuk
alors est-ce que ça va être bouillant
pour finalement flag et autant ouais ça
va ça va jouer le flag après après ça va
ça va jouer le flag ça c'est sûr mais
c'est normal en bullet ça finira et à 16
heures du coup le début de la finale
début de la finale à 16 heures du coup
on va voir si ça joue encore est-ce que
je vais jouer j'avais prévu de fait
j'avais prévu que ça finisse à 16 heures
du coup puisque j'avais pas caler la
petite finale et reprendre après as que
je vais glisser dans la foulée je sais
pas encore je pense je vais faire une
petite pause mais c'est bien qu'ils
enchaînent direct les deux matches que
déjà je trouve que ces longues et 3
trouve que trois heures pour voir deux
matches c'est un peu long franchement
prouve que ça un peu long j'arrête le
match de la troisième place avant mais
bon
parce qu'en fait c'est à dire pas
vraiment 30 minutes le truc ça dure plus
longtemps
les sections
comme s'arrête pas à 38 mais que ça
finit la partie du coût du coup les
matchs durent plus 1h 1h 40 qu'une heure
trente
bon alors
la rs 10 minutes pour elle enchaîne pas
bell font une pause mais en fait ça
pourrait peut-être récupérer la pause
pourrait peut-être être plus courte
suivant ce qui se passe
ben on va voir comment ça continue
savard est envoyé et donc le prochain
grand prix commencent mercredi aura uni
fans c'est quand même sympa ou ifan
alors
ça va bientôt repartir alors espérer que
vaille schalit face fasse le point
direct après on filera on filera sur la
finale donc à le commenter
tranquillement ce bull est on va pas
trop se mettre la pression parce qu'elle
est de l'écart en plus c'est une petite
finale
on essaiera de se faire un bon
commentaire comme ça en gardant
l'énergie pour pour la finale en bullet
si ça envoie allez on va chercher les
gaffes
ouais tu vois là il aurait pu envoyer à
51 ans vrai j'aurais pu faire une pause
plus courtes là je crois que ça a fini à
quarante sept îles et 53
by schalit qui se concentre normalement
il va prendre part aux vins italiens
oui fayen demande le chat qui là bas du
cou a exactement
non mais je pense que joua une zone
aussi était beaucoup plus forte
en fait je pense contre goût nina sont
les problèmes de connexion est là bas et
honnêtement joué ou jouent à jones a
joué nettement mieux je trouve jeu parce
qu'en pensez encore maxime baciu quoi
mais je trouvais que ça à jouer
nettement mieux
perso je joue à june j'ai vraiment eu
l'impression que ça a joué bien bas j'ai
beaucoup aimé en tout cas bon allez on
va voir petit petrov accueille ces trois
retourne dans un quatre cavaliers
alors je vous paye d4 et d5 schalit qui
bloque un peu ces affaires qui les
premiers singles et pendant cinq ans
après ça que la dame va être bien placé
tout cas kosteniuk 25 à 100 points elo
de plus en bullet ça peut ça peut faire
mal surtout que jaillit doit gagner 3 0
pour l'emporter le match car kia 54 donc
on verra à peu près à un fou des six
fait fou des quatre tours f1 f5 ray j'ai
l'impression que c'est sympa à jouer
pour les noirs en plus
du coup si vous prenez des livres les
gars n'hésitez pas à aller sur alfa
tchèque 1 sa part le livre de romain
edouard avoir g5 c'est un petit fou des
six il faut faire gaffe la intéressant
est ce que j'ai car trop risqué en
bullet jeu mais il doit faire c'est ici
soit le coup logique rapide peut-être un
petit coup de f5 aux siens qui peut
arriver allait reculer le front des six
mètres la dame en rose 5 pour menacer
m'a tout ça c'est des trucs logique et
dames 1 5
tmg 3pts f5 puis f4 puis j'ai quatre ça
va vite la côte est côté noir policiers
beaucoup plus agréable et un avantage
autant elle fait elle fait mal elle fait
mal alexandra et peut-être fois cinq à
les fous eux de fouet fin allez ça peut
défendre bas c'est vrai que ça va vite
avec les pions 1 4h 4 et elle va lui
mettre un pion angers 3 1 jour
lemay en h 3 allait peut-être fou g5
foot et de hockey le foin f3 j'aime bien
un petit coup de b6 c5 pour enfermer
ça c'était sûr allez maintenant il faut
réussir à percer allez vous prendre à
cinq classes et un pion quand même ouais
ça ça fait mal ça ça fait mal parce que
ses pions plus maintenant et il ya
toujours pas vraiment d'activité le fou
en c3 super bien placé
maintenant ça va aller jouer petit tour
g7 ou recettes ça va les jouer la
première rangée mais peut-être tour au
6e tour f 8 tours 8
elle avait fait un retour j'ai six tours
aussi ses plus forts la tour qui va
venir en e1 les blancs qui bouge pas un
poil le fou qui va arriver en g2 et
tourcoing f1 maths c'est game et ça fait
plus 3 bon voilà non plus à partie a été
quand même assez longue j'ai
l'impression elle a dû a dépassé les
trois minutes trente de loin pas de
tentatives de pâtes un taux aurait pu
tenter un patois avec food et 2 et toura
mais elle l'aurait vu
batch winx tremble pas et donc là elle a
besoin
je dirai juste en jouant deux parties
longues ce qui durent beaucoup de coups
ça devrait suffire mais si elle fait
juste une nulle la lequel qui va venir
en ses cinq voyages ou des trois aussi
un qui se joue donc à et c5 logique elle
va jouer le mauvais foucart et les g3 ça
j'ai du mal à comprendre pourquoi pas
être à lévis et le le truc mais doit
vouloir jouer le roi et sont attirés par
le roi alexandra joueuse très dangereuse
joueuses d'attac dynamique
c'est quoi ça à ces remises clic
bon ben là c'est game mesdames g4 h3 de
toute façon c'était un peu bizarre il ya
les fous et deux équipes rang avec 5
peut-être rester game dans tous les cas
il n'y aura pas de regret si c'est un
mythe cliquer là y aura jamais quatre
parties donc c'est fini
c'est fini de chez fini on s'arrête à un
match agréable quand même à suivre elle
a jailli ouais ouais c'est encore un peu
de temps mais pas de façon on savait à
la fin des 3 + 5 que scénique était au
dessus pour la veille schalit qui qui
donne tout maintenant mais à mais bon
y'a plus de la ya plus de peps 1 il n'y
a plus rien la dame qui arrive en h4
c'est finir bon ça aussi c'est fini
gamache 4 ça tire ça attire l'oeil
on va pouvoir faire un mat avec damien
mais il y aura toujours les cavaliers f1
qui vont couvrir elle jaillit c'est quoi
l'idée après fou prend un tour prend 1
et cavaliers f1 à tour prend des 1 et
surtout reprend des incas relief deux
mais c'est qu'un échange en fait ça a
juste perdu du matériel a perdu une
qualité dans les temps et ce tant dans
l'eure
ah non c'est bien connu qui attaquent
toujours et où c'est vrai voilà trait à
la fin la repère d'une qualité pour
trait au doigt mais bon après le match
et gagner tu vois quand à +4 comme ça
peut-être elle veut juste jouer une
partie qui dure honnêtement moi j'aurais
du mal à rester concentré là à la place
de costa nuke
enfin pour moi gagner 8 3 ou gagné 7,6
ça change rien et là tu sais que c'est
fini donc juste laisser tourner le temps
à maximum dans une partie donc quelque
part ça te fera toujours une partie de
moins à jouer
donc c'est plutôt plutôt logique ce
qu'elle est ce qu'elle fait alexandra
même ça va peut-être finir par la perdre
en tout cas par ne pas la gagner c'est
pas très important
elle joue beaucoup de coups dans cette
partie
ça c'est nul mais à mais bon en bullet
tu prends les blancs ce qui a créé à ce
pion là qui va ré en plus c'est à cette
idée là non c'était peut-être mieux pour
beaucoup mieux pour les blancs en plus
c83 la cac et prend ra prend a5 a6 a7 a8
aulas faut surtout pas faire ou à ses 7
non c'est bien voilà c'est l'opération
parfaite pour kosteniuk parti qui va
durer des plombes à l'échangé les dames
c'est logique non voilées va se
reprendre des échecs pour avoir saisi
trois sets et fo prend b6 échec
c'est dommage elle peut pas être changé
les dames baixa ya les blancs la veille
schalit qui va gagner
d'ailleurs même si kosteniuk souffre à
voile a pas fait qu alice est bon
c'est qu'elle ne souffre pas vrai nom
mais en vrai elle permet elle s'en fiche
c'était la dernière je pense en fait tu
en vises a fait durer la partie au moins
est au moins c'est game
et au moins c'est game one ressort à
retarder le début du deuxième match
parce qu'aujourd'hui comme c'est la
finale ils ont attendu tout cavailles
schalit qui s'incline très logiquement
quitter la salle c'est d'aller trouver
l'autre salle
et on va avoir du coup les deux joueuses
c'est plus kosteniuk c ou chez nina
qu'entre goût mina
on attend que ça se lancent à bientôt
partir je veux qu'ils ont eu raison pour
la finale d'attendre
d'attendre la fin de l'autre match je
trouve que c'est quand même bien bien
pensé alors le match qui va démarrer
d'ici quelques secondes vous ninacs doit
être en favorite ou génial inquiets qui
sue à la caméra elle sut un peu la
russie pour le doublé vrai troisième et
première et ou chez nina jose
ukrainienne du coup donc les joueuses
des pays de l'est à l'honneur dans ce
tournoi donc oui il ya 3000 dollars pour
la première 2000 milles et 700 donc aux
siens qui a pris mille dollars à
nationalité serrus congrue ci-contre
ukraine
l'ex urss pour un triplé exactement
c'est pas les drapeaux des bonnes
joueuses
ça va bientôt partir à l'action
soviétique est bien représentée et donc
ce soir à partir de 20h30 le solde
battle la sélection sera faite à 20
heures
on ne va pas me suivre sur twitter et un
retweet
pour qu'on ait un maximum de ce qu'ils
soient au courant du match les mecs un
peu ce qui se passe sans qu'on est bon
valentina qui a battu vladan tournoi
mais c'était un matin ça compte pas
donc 1
bas mais c'était le matin la partie donc
ça comptera évidemment la partie qui a
commencé va qui vient de commencer des
quatre cavaliers axis kiev 3 6 fois f k
donc un système de londres mais les
noirs qui n'ont pas mis le pion en d5
donc qu'ils se gardent la flexibilité et
valentina qui joue avec x 6 donc elle se
débarrasse du fond blanc mais bon il y
aura un peu la case 5
elle joue avec des six du goût donc à la
elle se met pas au centre elles se
gardent la case des cinq pour un
cavalier est ce que je serai tout le
temps en solo pour commenter pour ce
tournoi oui pour ce tournoi oui mais on
va mettre le car est peut-être en c4
désolé pour les gens qui préfèrent quand
c'est pas solo tu as des gens qui
préfèrent qu'on sait sous l'autre des
gens qui préfèrent qu'on sait pas solo
mais je pense que ce qu'on avait décidé
avec pièces comme ces deux comme c'est
de faire des ces deux mètres en duo à
partir de 15 minutes
ça fait partie un peu plus longue parce
que pour les beats et les bulles est
comme ça le fait bien en solo et que les
budgets sont pas infinies
du coup c'est plus ou moins la décision
qui a été prise à part pour les très
gros match où les très gros event
bon c'est un peu mieux pour les plans il
ya plus d espace
le x hd en voit qui est plus fort que le
fouet cette donc on va voir
c'est toujours mieux avec favret mais
bon c'est pas facile de le faire tu as
des gens qui préfèrent salle en tout cas
les audiences et plus ou moins ça dépend
c'est difficile de dire quand est ce que
c'est mieux ou pas ça dépend ça dépend
de la fréquence si c'est tout le temps
du haut ça devient moins bien je sais
j'ai pu voir tous les maîtrise les stats
et c'est donc faire tout le temps en duo
en fait c'est même négatif faire tout le
temps solo ça change pas grand chose que
de faire des duos mais c'est juste un
peu plus intéressant qualitativement
pour allegro haven t pour les parties
longues mais mais en soi
en fait dans les métriques ce pur et dur
c'est même mieux solo duo ce qui
m'étonne à chaque fois mais bon ça
dépend pour l'asim pour les blancs un
clerc mentale pions des six qui est
faible qui est seul talent à tour qui
vient en d1 qui va s'en prendre aux
pions des six talent carélie qui peut
rebondir vers des cinq prochaines
matches et est ce qu'on sera de savants
et ça va dépendre des matches ça
dépendra des matches
cavalli c3 ça remonte ouest parle
peut-être plus avec le chat je sais mais
parce qu'on est à deux sur les parties
longues sexe cousty donc c'est aussi
pour ça que ça donne cette impression
c'est pour ça que ça donne cette
impression puisque comme je disais il ya
une question de cadence donc ça va plus
il ya le chat quand c'est des cadences
quand c'est des cadences longue et ça a
moin lire le chat quand c'est des blitz
en tout cas ce dont je suis sûr c'est
que c'est mieux quand je suis seul en
bullet que c'est mieux quand c'est à
deux camps cédé 15 minutes plus et en
blitz j'en sais rien alors on va voir et
surtout reprend huit tours de d1 préfère
toujours jouer avec les blancs quand
même ce pion des six qui restent faibles
avec la tour en 1
thorpe en deux tours pour eux deux car
il est des quatre cavaliers f5 non mais
c'est mieux pour les blancs c'est sûr
c'est sûr est-ce que tu as le temps de
faire tour des huit des 5,6 j'aimerais
bien faire qui est des cartes sim et je
sais pas quel point j'adore les blancs
je sais pas à quel point ils sont
vraiment mieux mais j'adore quand je
vois un pion des six comme ça j'ai
tellement envie de jouer ça des heurts
puisque tu commences par tours d2 j'aime
bien tour des deux meilleurs sont très
bien ça c'est fou moins visuellement
j'adore j'adore les blancs mais je suis
reste in toujours les trucs comme les
pions faible je suis restée toujours
ça m'étonne pas je les trucs trop pâle
anciennes parfois
a été des 3 ou quoique dit l'ordi leur
dîme est à peu près égale donc tu vas
martin maxime a raison une nouvelle fois
marrant non maintenant on leur dit
préfère les blancs mais dans l'argent
qui est des quatre cavaliers f5 et le
plus bref si ces faibles ça la diff
je pense comme l'a fait j'ai 5 tours 8
tu vois après ça m'étonne pas en fait je
vois l'évaluation par rapport au niveau
de jeu des gars de mon niveau
comme ces gens qui sont proches de mon
niveau là qu'on regarde jouer du coup il
se passe des trucs que j'imagine en
quelque sorte
et du coup là les blancs se retrouve
vraiment mieux et au niveau de maxime
sûrement il voit d'autres trucs avec les
noirs du niveau au dessus et du coup tu
es plus mieux c'est marrant quand même
parce que là j'ai quatre cavaliers f5
fait super mal non si tu arrives à le
faire ce qu'elle joue
non mais c'est intéressant de voir que
c'est que l'évaluation de max et lé
rallye sont corrects pour des gens très
fort et qu'on évaluation pour le niveau
du coup mon évaluation fausse même
complètement fausse complètement pour av
c'est plus vérifié dans la partie je
trouve ça assez drôle je trouve ça assez
marrant
qui a et b 3 pour les non alors kébé 3
pour les noirs ça représente un problème
serait une bonne idée mais le problème
c'est qu'ils accueillent prend b3 dont
ça donnerait une pièce malheureusement
voilà on peut déjà commencé à raser le
pion ou pouvons mettre le cavalier f3
qui est rangée 5 plus fort bacquet fra
qu'étrangers 5 ça fait mal roy j'ai deux
mots qu'elle prend pas le pion elle
gagne pas le pion g5 j'avais peut-être
peur d'un caïd et 3 ou d'un truc où elle
a pas vu est la cavalière 3 kg 5 c'est
vraiment fort parce que tu prends sur
échec si je rate rien car élèves c'est
un cas elle veut pas de ce pion mais
elle va quand même le gagner quoiqu'il
en soit même si elle ne veut pas elle va
forcément le gagne pain et on attend
candidature à roye f3 puisque sa menace
de pions donc b3 tour gk3 f3 donc b3 et
fort et très logique en plus son pion et
attaquent et tuent le protège
brive 3 laisse le pion c4
bon ça reste mieux parce que j'ai 5 et
super faible et qui a valu aux quatre
arrivées au prochain c'est quand même
assez bien joué pour les blancs
on devrait la gagner ana al haouz
chemise avec les pièces blanches qui
devrait réussir à l'emporter dans cette
première partie mais b3 expliqué la tour
et b3 pas rester logique puisque tout
reprend gk3 f3 et plus de cases bon mais
ça va quand même ce qu'elle a fait avec
les blancs elle a réussi à gagner le
pion et la finale et bien je trouve
je trouve que la finale est agréable
pour ou chez nina mais bon faut pas trop
se tromper non plus cette caisse j30
recueille ces cinq pour protéger attaqué
j'ai g4 et qui avalise ses sept pour
menacer qui est des cinq caisses et sept
sur les parties pour ça ce que tu
protèges l'a6 tu menaces l'attaqué des
cinq qui rôderait ça peut faire nul ça
parce que ça peut rentrer dans une
finale de tournoi et j'ai encore pire
jean roy f3 qui est des cinq tours bouge
tout retour f4 à y aura encore droit g3
mais ça va faire nul ça mais quel
dessein classé nul tout de suite tourné
six cavaliers prendre tout reprend roi
g7
bonjour à toute épreuve j'avais pas fais
ton projet 4 tu vois
j'aurais pas aimé garder fou contre
cavaliers vrai mais c'est du blitz donc
à loisir que lecavalier
elle peut faire les pièges mais fou
contre cavaliers avec les pions sur les
deux ailes
ouais mais ça fait peur parce que
pourquoi tu as regardé les cavaliers le
fou est beaucoup plus fort a et giove
sur deux elle est ce qu'elle va dans ton
rêve de fou pranger cinq tours prend b2
elle a déjà perdu un fou contre
cavaliers du coup je vous annonce
victoire blanche allait le commentateur
français prend ses responsabilités ils
annoncent une victoire blanche belle en
a déjà perdu
j'annonce non elle n'a pas appris à
défendre entre temps c'est sûr c'est sûr
c'est sûr
même là le pion est dur à gagner par
contre ça va peut-être pas y avoir la
victoire blanche
c'est quand même marrant c'est dommage
c'est dommage mais là c'est bien le
clouage qu'elle a fait tu peux ouais tu
vas pouvoir te débrouiller mais tu vas
perdre beaucoup de temps elle veut pas
je pensais que son idée c'était de près
le 3 je pensais que son idée c'est
d'enlever la tour est l affaire 3 des 5
es fou des cats je pense marrant marrant
je sais qu'elle voulait mettre le foin
des quatre mois je vous écouterai
bizarre avec avec les blancs et ça peut
être super déstabilisant ce qu'elle fait
c'est plutôt bien c'est complètement nul
théorique way la partie qui va durer
très longtemps
mais à voir les cinq ans de coups joués
ici c'est sûr on n'arrive vraiment pas à
gagner le pion
c'est elle le gagne elle gagnera la
finale c'est sûr on a l'impression
qu'elle ne gagnera pas mais roi des cinq
coups des quatre elle veut jamais en
fait ça j'ai compris aulas a peut-être
il y trois des cinq tours d2 fou des
quatre qui gagne et le pion à la patente
et le piège c'est dommage
elle aurait pu enfin tenter un piège à
la paf et montréal des 50 coût 50 coups
sans coût de pions ou sans prise ça fait
une nulle du coup je vous annonce qui
aura qui aura pas plus trois parties
dans cette section 5 + 1 on a dépassé
allègrement les 10 minutes de jeu en
vide à m'accepter
j'avais jamais vu dit rotastic wayne
rooney n'a bien gérée way ou chez nina
quand même très mal joué la finale a
honnêtement
alors elle a refusé les cavaliers f3 qui
avait projet 5 elle a refusé beaucoup de
choses hein elle a refusé beaucoup de
manières de de l'emporter afin de
l'emporter de prendre un gros avantage
et finalement ça aurait pu
ça aurait pu coûter pas ça lui a coûté
finalement ça aurait pu coûter à guînes
à mon avis ça peut être un avantage
psychologique à un prix par la joueuse
russe
je se sont concentrés le nom de vertus
avec les blancs c'est un gambit dame
après je pense que le fait que joe de
toi avec les joueuses françaises c'était
plus sympa ça venait plus de la delà du
format que qu'autre chose que des
joueuses parce que le format 17 et plus
et plus vivent peut-être un petit dame
g4 ici tandis qu'adam g 4 c'est le foot
est roi emprise l'est d'alger quatre ça
va arriver
je pense que oui nina peut faire très
très mal ici
je pense que ça peut faire extrêmement
mal peut-être mais tu ne tournes d1 en
premier à l'envoi dame g4 direct f5 va
être quasi obligé un j'ai l'impression
je suis ça fait quand même super peur
13,5 aussi en vrai mais moi je suis tjrs
à quoi tu dois peut-être faire un ff
c'est un crève 5
ce que le purin quatre horaires et enfin
c'était tellement mal il faut prendre 6
qui rôde et c'est allé prendre à quatre
c'est courageux il ya qui est des six
qui vient qui vient sûreté epr en a
quatre et tout
ouais
ça fait hyper mal et à quel point aussi
ce qui rôdent ça peut être une grosse
cartouche là
c'est terrible ce terrible ya tout
proche si ceux-ci qui m'a l'astre
alors f5 j'avais pas lu d'alger sinon
plus c'est game je pense je pense
égaliser à 4 4 pour un f4 reprend des
cas pas sur vous prend 1,6 à la tour g4
ou au bien joué ça
n'est ce pas du tout - ouais je pensais
que c'était games et pas game j'avais
pas vu cavalière 4 j'avais raté car et
les f4
c'est peut-être mort mais pas pour les
noirs et j'ai pas vu hef cinq cavaliers
f4 c'était bien joué elle n'avait pas vu
à l'avance non plus hein c'est tombé par
chance entre guillemets la réussite côté
côté anna vanina avec les blancs y avait
un truc qui semblait bien se passer
mal et rien n'est fait encore dans cette
partie sur dame cécilia toujours f3 pour
couvrir mais bien vu maxime à thann 17
quel sens va du cloud âge
cavaliers des six
c'est intéressant
debbasch penser ça ça et ça mais de quoi
inciter à tour ses sept terrifiant
h3 cette fois çi c'était une idée mais
elle peut juste faire rage suite aux
pires ou tout autre coup il faut surtout
pas qu'elle fasse carrillo 4c game torse
et 7
compliqué dams et 6 f3 tourcoing f4
qu'elle a refilé une calloc'h encore
d'un match d'avant c'était une autre
joueuse je sais pas ce sacré
elle s'active à fond quand même voilà
beaucoup de temps elle joue vite
elle joue vite vanina ça pourrait lui
servir quand la cadence sera dans les
cadences seront plus rapides mais c'est
la deuxième fois laquelle se retrouvent
pas super bien
bon
position dobre pour les blancs secs fiso
qualité était assez bien et encore un
pion qui tombe ça va encore tomber en b2
alors un tour ces huit là j'imagine un
kabyle six nations c'est qu'elle vous a
activé sa tour mais c'est très bien joué
aussi
c'est pas ça se passe bien un petit coup
de tours fc être pas laisser le matin à
ça c'est réussi à lui maasdam prend h6
maintenant bref quatre bien joué elle
protège au passage vanina qui donne tout
pour l'attaqué comme d'hab
pas d'hésitation ça envoie
kessé 4e 5 et les premiers froids à
venir kessé katrina sera cavaliers 3
normalement ça à faire le point pas de
finale aller la foca me rentrer dedans
la finale doit être gagnante 1 il ya
quoi il ya un deux trois pions pour la
qualité
il ya le pur à qui va aller jusqu en a
deux elle empêche pour le moment
allez faut il changer une paire de tours
la règle du off anderson tu as deux
tours elle en a une dont qu'il faut
échanger pour plus qu'à les deux tours
et toi t'en garder une qui peut faire le
taf
essayez roi des 4 3 3 des 4 as et cinq
fauves et 5 fu b3 elle défend
allez c'est pas encore tout à fait fini
même si c'est dur
tours d2 pour ces cinq années
car pas en f1 j'imagine foods de hal et
montrent le roi en d4 peut-être c'est
dommage qu'ils allaient pas échanger les
tours ce qu'elle pourrait essayer avec
le roi de venir en avant c'est dur de
jouer des coups avec les blancs ce
qu'elle va faire fou d un parent à six
parce qu'elle veut partir en bessin
imagine peut-être s'activer avec la
toile et elle s'activait à tour ces deux
bons ça répète un peu évidemment les
noirs veulent pas nul hein
c'est vraiment très galère là pour les
blancs les partis qui dure je pense
qu'on va réussir à voir que deux parties
en 5 + 1 si c'est possible une fois ce
serait dans ce match
parce qu'elle est partie dure vraiment
beaucoup de coups à combien de couleurs
nos cinquante et unième al elle finit
par pousser surtout pas tout reprend
bekhadda et des cinq a été atteint petit
prise est fou c'est 4 va faire pousser 4
je pense paraît logique mais l'option
afin l'avantagent noir qui épuise son
tour ces deux qui est des 5es et b4
qu'elle va faire tôt ou tard alors y'a
pas tout reprendre de la non y avait
chaque pardon excusez moi excusez moi
une statue six nations de ma part c'est
sa part de tous les côtés alors est ce
qu'elle doit jouer le tour prend bekkat
elle va tomber si elle le fait sur trois
devait y jouer tempo à les rois f2 tour
ces deux faut essayer de résister à les
apprendre eux quatre tous rêvent de sa
défense à roy prend h3 elle peut pas et
c'est fini risquer une autre partie vous
parlez je crois de justesse de justesse
ça aurait pu faire que deux parties au
chrono ça aurait été marrant il y aura
quand même une troisième deux parties
très longue et ou chez nina qui a fini
par l'emporter
il va y avoir fois ci ce qu'elle a
préparée vanina pour ce tournoi
5e le combat est âpre 1 mais dans les
deux parties à vanina a été dominée
ça aurait pu 1 c'était pas gagné pour
les blancs au début si si les blancs
étaient bien à un moment donné puis ça
s'est retourné un peu tout seul j'ai
envie de dire mais gagnant s'était pas
le moment les blancs étaient mieux
comment se faire sélectionner pour les
bras bafouille sur le stream bitstream à
20h antichoc là comme d'habitude en fait
c'est toujours la même chose seul
avantage donc chez nina donc j'allais
blanc dans celle-là elle n 1 et demi 1/2
il va falloir faire enfler le score les
amis valentina la plus rapide donc je
pense que les cadences à venir vont lui
profiter tout cas c'est mon point de vue
pressez pas obligé que j'ai raison mais
mais de mon point de vue ça va les
favoris ça va ça va favoriser sa
favoriser valentina donc il faut que
cana en profite dès maintenant pour pour
faire l'écart et prendre de points
d'avance ce soir c'est pour tous niveaux
il faut être abonné à la chaîne
bitstream
dan 17 avoir un 4 way là une nouvelle
fois il ya c'est la même position que la
première il ya une grosse prise d'
espaces pour les blancs mettre les tours
en d1 et c'est un jeu pensé préparé une
poussée ses cinq plus imagine pour faire
jouer le foot attache 3 en premier
l'histoire deux
tout cas grosse performance
est-ce que becca très faible en b 4 il
va plutôt soutenir une poussée 5,4
faible
page 6
peut-être dc5 possible avoir un avoir
mach 3 thual aurait pu commencer par h3g
travail préparé ses 5 c'est clair elle
va y aller saluons nantis au cce c'est
plutôt il faut h2 et ses cinq noms
danbé de sa manoeuvre et h5 fouache 2
suis pas trop où elle veut en venir
elle fait fou ou trois ans peut-être 5.1
pour se libérer du coup f5
elle envoie avec beaucoup de conviction
comme souvent à faire j'ai 5 fu g7 f4 g4
est là pour ça l'afev cattrall et elle
est partie pour pour ça ça fait pas très
très peur mais bon ça peut ça peut
devenir effrayant un moment donné
ça peut le devenir
quoi qu'il va rentrer en a certes dominé
quand même allé dominer chez une action
quand même beaucoup mieux dans ce début
de match
pour ces 1 qui va arriver avec bien
concentré et pion qui par an ces cinq
gardés menace avec db6 qui vont rodez
c'est dur
très dur là pour pour les noirs ces cinq
très fort surpris en premier à b6 ça à
faire de 0,1 ça va faire 2 0 les amis je
pas si vous voyez bien le score en fait
sa fiche est est-ce qu'on voit bien sur
ordi le score ce qu'il a affichée mais
c'est vrai que c'est ça rend peut être
pas super grand
n'iront pas super grand
peut-être est-ce que le récupérer pour à
pour l'agrandir
en attendant il s'est passé quoi on
pensait que ça allait faire game mail
une bouilloire qui ont réussi à s'en
sortir un bien jouer valentine a bien
joué et valentina qui s'en sort et qui
n'a pas récupéré b6
la récupérer b si c'est pour mettre le
pion en d5 et houcine avait été
championne du monde est
a été championne du monde n'a pas été
numéro 1 mondiale elle a été championne
du monde et qui en 17 bon problème reste
toujours entier pour les noirs s'est
trouvé le contre eux je mène d'un québec
croit ici pour venir reprendre du cavale
mais éventuellement
c'est ce qu'à la jouer
saddam à 6
victoire je suis surpris de voir les
champions du monde je vais pour 2000 à
wemmel championne du monde il ya très
longtemps et ensuite 2000 pour un
tournoi qui dure quatre jours où tu
joues à 1h30 par jour quand tu gagnes
puis c'est pas 2000 c'est 3000 c'est pas
si peu un sur quatre semaines tu gagnes
sur les trois semaines se gagne les
trois tu prends 9000 puisque la finale
je peux prendre quatorze mille quand
même des échecs c'est quand même pas un
enjeu majeur
tu france championnat lambda de ping
pong féminin c'est plus médiatisé
peut-être et savaient pas les pays mais
je suis pas sûr que tu es beaucoup plus
sain un championnat lambda
gaia enfin tu prends les lutteurs mais
les lutteuses encore pire mais les gars
les gars les gars vont gagner 1500 euros
quand ils vont être champions du monde
quoi donc c'est pas si peu hein
c'est pas si peu en réalité en soi bon
les noms à la qui réussissent à bien
tenir je dis pas que c'est beaucoup non
plus hein
après pourra utiliser au oui mais il
gagnera rien aux jioi gagnant 1 puis là
c'est pas des yeux c'est un tournoi
lambda championne du monde d'échecs
c'est plus qu'on ait enfin je sais plus
combien le prend mais c'est plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'euros
tu peux pas comparer les les jo à un
tournoi sur internet quoi ouais c'est un
camp de calais médaille d'or c'est
beaucoup moins que ce que gagnent les
joueuses d'échec c'est beaucoup moins
pour quelque chose qui sont beaucoup
plus médiatique donc il faut pas non
plus et c'est une fois tous les quatre
ans je l'aï monde d'échecs c'est une
fois tous les deux ans donc
théoriquement tu peux le gagner deux
fois plus souvent c'était vraiment le
meilleur
l'annuaire d' approcher à grands pas
vrai parce que je perds le match a team
france mans ce soir on a le on a le soft
battle renault bon alors ça va être la
pause ou chez nina qui a raté beaucoup
d'occasions 1
elle a eu beaucoup davantage raté
elle est beaucoup d'occasions ratées on
va voir si ça lui coûte cher je pense
que c'est plutôt valentina qui sort
devant de ce premier set même si elle a
perdu de ce premier ce premier segment
buvez de l'eau gazeuse lui devig ne
gazeuse bien connue des [ __ ] italien
comme moi j'ai envie dire notre eau
gazeuse favorite
ouais
c'est de la belle eau gazeuse là c'est
de l'eau gazeuse qualitatif donc le
match qui va reprendre dans 5 minutes
j'imagine
je pense que celle d'havas va souffrir
dans les cadences à venir faut vraiment
qu'elle essaye de prendre deux trois
points d'avance dans le 3 + 1 qu'elle
regagne encore plus à la prochaine
section
c'est quoi la règle quand il ya plus de
temps tu as perdu
donc
on va voir
on va voir comment ça va ça va ça
révolue et
les gens viennent se garer en bas de
chez moi
donc j'ai ina qui se lève pas un qui
restent devant l'ordinateur sont pas
partis faire une petite pause
elle aurait pu alors réduit même à mon
avis
tina qui revient on sera bientôt
repartir pour la deuxième phase
une première phase qui aura duré
longtemps presque 40 minutes de jeu
ce que le jeu se voient entre à louis
peuvent éventuellement se voir mais je
pense pas que je pense pas qu'elle
qu'elle le fasse parce que ça prend du
temps et de la concentration
je pense pas que tu es vraiment le temps
de gérer ça
ça va bientôt repartir à mon avis
donc moi je mettrais vous mettriez qui
moi jouer trémoulinas favorite
maintenant malgré le score
je mettrai au chili nous allons bien sûr
la finale soir valentina à la pac à fond
un l attaque à fond
elle fait pas dans la dentelle j'ai
envie de vous dire j'ai voté valentina
moi on va voir ce que ça donne
alors on fait vraiment chaud aujourd'hui
il faisait bon tout à l'heure il s'est
mis à faire très chaud la plus de gens
qui sont pour et qui pensent pour china
va gagner on verra on verra
dan au score mais son âge n'ont vraiment
pas du tout le chat non mais je dis
souvent que le chat ne représente pas
forcément quand on parlait des audiences
et c'est tout à l'heure par exemple
parfois ce que tu lis sur le chat quand
tu demandes la vie des gens est ce que
tu vois dans les statistiques et dans
les metrics après c'est assez différent
ça peut arriver que ce soit assez
différent ça c'est intéressant
d'ailleurs le chat n'est pas du tout
toujours représentatifs c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que je disais tout à l'heure que
parfois quand on commenté qu'on répond
beaucoup au chat
les gens qui sont actifs dans le chat du
couvent est clair que c'est très bien
mais mais en fait la majorité des gens
n'écrivent pas un seul message dans le
tchat
donc il faut il faut raison garder
répondre au chat mais pas trop le faire
non plus toute la difficulté de ce tri
mais c'est au bout de combien de points
qu'on gagne c'est une question de temps
il ya du ccc plus du temps que ses
segments 30 minutes 30 minutes et dix
minutes
alors je suis d'accord avec toi tu
trouves que c'est pas très malin mais
c'est comme ça et ça lui mr abe et
gardiens
ça reprend pas pour le moment salut ou
de maths
salut aux mêmes jouent axe monsieur rêve
qu'ils aident dans un état sûr tant dans
le chat ta tête 10 20% dès gens qui
écrivent maximum maximum
allez c'est reparti ça coco pops qui
créeront ils trouvent que l'expriment
sont bons merci à toi
six français quatre toute façon
l'événement va durer quatre semaines en
place un premier grand prix qui finit on
en reprend un deuxième mercredi puis un
troisième le mercredi d'après puis un
autre le mercredi d'après là c'est le
pion isoler ces nouveaux un grand vide à
m'accepter grandes variantes
on va voir si vanina maîtrise le pion
isoler aussi bien que vlad
qu'est ce que ce soir on gagne là ça
m'étonnerait avec la finale dimanche
donc fable de fabrice et la finale
précédée d'une petite finale pour la
troisième place que je ne savais pas
dans le top 10 et dans les horaires
qu'on va envoyer de base c'était pas
noté du tout alors là l'idée des plans
en gros souvent de faire des cinq là
maintenant vu comment elle a fait ou
d'attaquer le roi mais vu comment les
pièces sont classés 5e des 5 donne envie
mais elle peut jouer aussi pour
cavaliers pro f 7 tours 1 est prise
aussi ce nom michel devra y gagnent
quasiment tous les to les soldes battle
ils sont très durs à battre
en fait ils perdent que contre alexandra
et alix on vend on l'a jamais battu donc
je suis pas super confiant d'un autre
côté c'est vrai combat on a battu
gravelines guechoud je sais pas mais la
nymphe on a pris une telle cartouches
bon prix de 5 c'est bizarre de basta pas
envie mais peut-être a été obligé
puisque tu ouvres la colonne des mtt
clio 4 qui est décisif et peut-être que
ça va
dams et 7 pouces et deux tours des
trois-tours h3 je pense qu'elle va
essayer de partir pour tour des 3 c dans
son style à valentina non si y'a pas un
problème grave
elle en rit tout rage 3 elle va attaquer
le roi j'imagine
ouais c'était sûr c'était sur quelques
jours et comme ça valentina
allait elle va mater la valentine à
c'est sûr aller j'annonce j'annonce
l'égalisation de valentina
sorti par an age 3
ai-je annonce qu'elle va vouloir faire
fou prend 1,7 qui prend h7 d'arâches 5
normes et la torah je crois c'est sûr tu
a tout fait pour je sais pas quoi elle a
réfléchi 1 a laissé bien aller c'est
bien valentina dame c4 alors elle
empêche l empêche vous prendre cavaliers
prendre damage 5-fu eu quatre balles et
un pâle choix damage 5 quand même un
aime ça perd peut-être sur le champ d'un
point f4 fou prend h7 roi fuite
il y aura des damage sissouane en
mettant vos allées on voit damage saint
calais ballet qu'un ça va marcher parce
qu'ils auront un damier 4 un clouage à
la fin peu importe mais tu peux envoyer
damage saint calais il faut y aller avec
damage 5 la halle et valentina elle perd
elle prend beaucoup de temps à flot d'un
match 5 c'est sûr que c'est le premier
coup au cas elle a pensé mais n'arrive
pas à calculer dames 1re quatre fois je
sais tu fous g6 j'imagine dame g4 sympa
fou g6 du bouffou cake par dams et 4
bondam 3 c'est dommage maintenant il ya
b4 et il ya le foot c'est 2 qui peut
rester en l'air le voit pas et
heureusement c'est dommage de pas avoir
mis cette dame en cinq ans même mois la
foux enfin c'est chaud il ya peut-être
des dames g4 aussi
tours j'ai trois fous pranger 5 je
pensais ouais c'est bien joué ça parce
que là tout ranger 5 est super mal placé
la tour vient en d2 c'est dommage qu'il
n'ait pas fait un match 5 vraiment tout
à l'heure je serai à tour ses 8 et b4
b4 foulée 3 c'est un vrai bébé qu'à
trouver 3 je voulais essayer de faire
dame g4 à ce moment là du coup ça aurait
pu donner la même variante sauf que
j'aurais eu des français à la fin pour
menacer à gagne facile aussi
ces pièces de plus six coups de hache si
cela se fait pas de mal salle carlier pu
rebondir en dessin en 5
elle va bouffer e5
je pense non elle le laisse en vie
pourquoi pas mais a de toute façon qu'il
s'était hissé système pas plus malin ça
stabilise plus facilement la position et
ça va faire une victoire de plus
pour anna torcéen tour ces deux salaires
forme ni variés compoint f2 barrès
qu'elle va sauver ce pion non alors
maintenant cette crise accueille ses six
tours à huit empreintes f7 mais y'aura
qui est ok faut tenter de façon je pense
toujours à huit tours prend at on
croyait cette fois qu'il prend 1,5 à
accra là et là a donc accueilli il ya le
il ya eu 5 qui tombe et de cavaliers qui
revient à m6 ce terrible mais valentina
vraiment le damage cinq pages ou est ce
étonnant c'est tellement un coup dans
son style c'est très étonnant qu'elle ne
l'est pas à jouer et là le point va être
pris à coup sûr elle a filé un pion en a
assez moins claires là tout d'un coup à
cavaliers avec af si ce nom n ya rien
pour le moment
mais le fils et le pion h en un c'était
pas l'idée du siècle et salue crypte al
richy s'il est jugé sage et 6ème et tu
veux te fait envoyer un pouvait
peut-être envoyer des dames à chis des
fous g5 des trucs en tout cas c'était un
coup vraiment dans son style à elle a ou
chez nina qui a longtemps en championnat
du monde avait raté pour fou contre
tours cavaliers fouquet normalement il
sait pas maté si elle n'a pas appris
depuis normalement elle sait pas mater
tout le monde le sait moi on valide à
elle doit prendre et courir avec trois
tracés dommage de pas prendre tout de
suite
il est capable de plus être en
possibilités de
cavalia h4 et l'option va aller à dame
sans qu'elle puisse le prendre c'est
tellement dommage de pas de deux pas
juste prendre des rentrées non mais
c'est au la décision horrible
oh c'est affreux à ces affreux pour tu
dois juste prendre le pouls est rentrée
dans le fou cavaliers c'est connu
qu'elle sait pas le faire alors c'est ya
huit ans mais c'est sûr que ça lui met
la pression et du public elle valeureux
raté grâce à tes sûr qu'elle aurait raté
une deuxième fois avec peu de temps tu
driver droits jusqu'en 1 comme un pot
tepa et c'était bon tu restes un peu au
centre en plus ce n'était pas facile la
position de départ au la mauvaise
décision c'était sûr que le plus l
amènera dame facilement et qui
pourraient plus échangées quelle
mauvaise décision
problème c'est qu'elle aurait pu le
faire une deuxième fois non mais tu sens
pas qu'elle l'aurait raté maxime fou
cavaliers honnêtement si tu fais des
côtes
je pense le fait qu'elle leur atsé 1,60
et elle le réussit avons fait quota de
50 à moi je te dis alors est raté
franchement ça lui aurait mis la
pression de leurs ratés a promis
n'importe quoi elle a déjà raté une fois
dans un truc important tu y arrives
caveau je suis pas si j'arrive
maintenant c'est le roi est bien placé
que j'ai dix secondes spyer c'est pas
sûr que j'y arrive ça fait trop
longtemps que j'ai pas obligé pas révisé
il ya longtemps j'avais réussi à le
faire avec 12 13 secondes déjà eu
beaucoup de chance ou 15
parce que j'avais révisé ya pas
longtemps trahi aurait pu le rater ça
mérite au moins lui mettre la pression
quoi c'est genre de trucs qui peuvent
faire tourner le match gratuit déçu pour
valentina là elle avait
ça méritait de ceux tentés
ça méritait de ceux tentés ça aurait mis
un peu de un peu de drame à
ça aurait mis un peu de drame à presse
avec alors il faut aller probablement
appris et tout mais ça te met peut-être
un peu de pression tu sais qu'il ya du
public
machin est tout tu peux de chocques avec
peu de temps bon façon c'était mieux ça
que de la perdre en quatre coups en
laissant dame est de toute façon c'était
sûr que le punir adam facilement ya du
public et 10 secondes à la pendule ce
pas si simple passe et est moins simple
que ce qui s'est passé tout du moins
c'était moins simple barça se voyait
qu'elle était dégoûté de ne pas avoir
pris
ouais ça y est je le rappelle qu'on
faisait des 3a des trois mille 3000 tous
cavaliers avec mirta c'est tout j'étais
celui qui arrivait lit mieux d'ailleurs
dans le groupe des gens qui faisait je
me rappelle j'étais vraiment rapide pour
ça mais depuis j'ai perdu le skill mal
en pis ça n'était pas facile le roi il
était un peu au centre il était proche
d'un angle belle et ils n'étaient pas
pas facile facile ma position de départ
était chiante
bon allez valentina là faut revenir à
mon avis elle est toujours dans le game
parce que les gros scores du surfaces
comme les régimes fit sont la même chose
non il faut faut égaliser les amis
focal ayana si elle perd cela ça fait
marrer dame c4 ça fait mal sa force les
changes des dames ça attaque les
français 4 et prend des six
allez à ça fait 3 points d'écart ça va
faire très très mal
de fou c'est facile ce matériel dame
prend 1,4 je pense qu'à apprendre de la
dame en quatre ouais j'ai même prendre
h4 est rentré dans la finale en se
disant kurdes 1.461 la finale encore en
améliorer d'un proche 4 c'est vraiment
logique car à des fins qui ça c'est
étonnant parce que maintenant il ya
alger d'un proche cas ça me paraissait
logique mais il ya peut-être quelque
chose que j'ai pas compris parce que du
coup en fait soit tu rentrais dans la
finale et bon c'était elle vient de
refuser deux fois une meilleure finale
donc c'est une finale de pire en pire
donc d'après le déroulement de la partie
c'était plutôt content et si elle refuse
les échanges des dames tu avais la même
position avec encore un pion h de quoi
en plus c'est pour ça que ça paraît
logique ce que tu es quand même content
d'avoir un pion h 2 même si ça va très
bien quand même bien qu'à une tour ces
six là et ça rentre pour 6,6 tu vas
prendre mais ça va juste pensé que
c'était encore plus facile avec dame
prend h4 mais elle gère très bien sa
partie la hausse chez nina et le match
d'un point de vue plus général faudra
faire attention en bullet simplement
à tours qui va venir en bessette qui va
clouer l'adamant ces quatre là tout est
couvert même pas de [ __ ] en g3 ya rien
tout est bien protégé bref cette tour 7
pardon je pensais que la tour était venu
plus loin et oui ça menace le fou
meilleurs joueurs price est maintenant s
était sûr vous prend f2 prise f2 à et
ben voilà on va peut-être la voir notre
réponse annonce hayatou reprend f2
encore pire à g j'avais temps un temps
espoirs sur foot pro f 2 et le thon
rouge le fou cavaliers que je les ratés
aussi l'espoir fou cavaliers pour voir
si maxima et raison bon ça fait 3 ou
même 4 1 non ça c'est une bande connue
en fait maintenant qu'ils jouent un peu
c'est un peu bizarre mais les blancs
vouloir faire ces trois rois c2 et vont
avoir une finale un peu un peu
avantageuse laurence et 2 va être bien
placé mais les blancs kemp est en avance
dans une position symétrique les pièces
un peu mieux placé
4 et pour commencer aux échecs que
monsieur mais ce tango je te conseille
de regarder sur czech comme les séries
vidéo à mon avis c'est ce qui peut être
le plus sympa à mon avis c'est ce qui
peut être le plus sympa pour m'inspirer
d'art un truc complet d'avoir un peu
tous les outils et ça ne coûtera
finalement pas beaucoup plus cher que
plusieurs livres
bon faut espérer une victoire de
valentina là pour remettre du suspens
combien de temps pour passer de débutant
au niveau de 2000 sur chaise comme à 4-3
quatre ans je pense si tu suis try hard
tu try hard à mon avis trois quatre ans
valentine égale green in a way son
prénom
mike fincke food mc collum est
impossible puisque tu pourras jamais
attaqué une des deux couleurs
comment on fait pour tailler pour
chaises comme faut envoyer un cv renault
faut tu regardes les positions qu'ils
sont libres a envoyé un cv ça va faire
pousser 4 je pense il y aura pas tout
reprendre et de yacks et prend des 2ème
et laqué ouais je passe le fougerais
bien mais l'échangé en fait pour revenir
avec lecavalier
alors
non mais c'est bien ce qu'elle fait se
passe pas grand chose pour le moment la
finale est restée égale non ils vont
réussir à mettre un carré en f4
finalement et à avancer éventuellement -
elle veut tout est changé aussi elle
veut peut-être dire il ya aussi le score
du match 1 qui rentrent en jeu dans les
décisions le fait que tu mènes le fait
quand les parties durent longtemps ça te
favorise clairement avec les noirs là
maintenant pour anna je suis pas
exactement 1 combien d'heures de combien
il reste deux temps là dans le dans la
cadence je vais aller jeter un oeil de
paresthésie dix minutes certes il va
rester salarié oui ok il reste salah et
une ou deux peut-être plus tôt
je catch aime bien elle va commencer à
vouloir jouer la case f4
mais un poste vacant streamer
francophone charismatique ouais je
croirais je crois qu'on a besoin de ça
on veut éviter le burn out
bon alors
s'ils jouaient ce qu'il ya reprise
de fait elle peut prendre je pense parce
que quand tu fais un échec à tours
bessette
mais je veux jouer comme ça et ça peut
être je suis ans avec vous prend à 6 ce
qui arrive je comprends pourquoi
pourquoi anna hésite je comprends tout à
fait son d'hésitation ça c'est encore
une partie qui est parti pour durer 1
les amis que des parties de fond de
court c'est curieux coup de partida
taquin finalement danse dans ce tournoi
quand on compare avec les veines qu'on
avait organisé sur bitstream c'est moins
en moins offensif un sac on a eu la
chance d'avoir admira qui envoie
beaucoup et donc il y avait offert
énormément de partie data qu'on avait
démentez aussi qui est une joueuse très
offensive
donc c'est vrai qu'on avait pas mal déjà
quand tu as deux joueuses très offensive
là c'est vrai qu'elle n'aurait n'ont pas
réussi vraiment envoyé
mettre le fond ces quatre je pense ça
faisait quatre france 3 mais bon
peut-être tourache un entourage suite
vous reprochera peut-être je vois mme la
tourache un fou ou six tours h8 arief
progressiste la part dont je suis débile
rouge et quatre tours h 8 tours 17 x 5
ouais mais bon faut calculer jusque là
elle n'a pas vu l a pas vu x 5 à la fin
alex plutôt une bonne nouvelle pour le
match vanina très bien joué à faire tout
reprend des huit champs juste m'en fou
prend des huit marrant dur à passer
offensif jusque-là
puis un style offensif pas je sais pas
je pense qu'on va papa pas spécialement
finalement ça attendait un truc plus
offensif mais ça joue plus technique
avec 6 jouanne jun avait avait gagné
avec une connexion normal à mon avis
elle aurait pu faire très mal dans ce
tournoi c'est avec valentina qui joue
bien mais jouer john était vraiment une
tête au dessus
voilà ça va gagner moins de gaffe quand
même dans ce match que dans que dans les
autres matches donc ça joue jusqu'au
bois
c'est pas compliqué à gagner ouais bah
ça c'est bien fait normalement roi pions
contre roye ça pose de problème à
personne il va y avoir droit et fuite
encore un petit coup n'ont même pas
aller ça gagne il doit rester une
dernière partie dans la cadence on va
les vérifier
vérifier ça parce qu'il doit pas rester
malgré six minutes et qu'il peut en
rester une ou deux ça dépend et je
voudrais qui marque une petite pause
chez nike qui a fermé les yeux
ça reprend pas on sait pas pourquoi
marque une petite pause il marque une
petite pause alors ça reprend
c'est toujours ça être même position
mais j'aime bien les blancs à chaque
fois empressé la prépa de de vanina
d'axa doit pas être nouvelle est bien
préparée ça doit être complètement
corrects ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle joue
avec les noirs mais je trouve que les
blancs ont toujours été bonne position à
surfer ce b 4 à 4 là elle a réussi à
prendre beaucoup d espace à chaque fois
c'est pas une petite pause au milieu un
peu bizarre mais bon pourquoi pas toute
façon je pense pas que ça rajoute
s'enlève deux parties dans le truc mais
soit vanina différemment elle joue avec
des cinq plus tôt elle se laisse pas
marcher dessus
c'est un gars surprise la dame prend à 6
1 c'est ça le problème
où là il ya ces six là où la houle à la
houle à la c6 généralement ça fait super
mal tu obligé de faire dame c8 le pion
va être un tel problème
elle fait passer si ça alors ça ça ça
m'étonne c'est si ça donnait vraiment
très envie ans c'est peut-être moi qui
capte rien après
mais peut-être aussi la fatigue mais ça
que ça a donné très envie aussi mais
c'est si ça est tellement envie
mais non c'est dur ce que tu m'as à ses
6 km s'était arrimé jitsu hradecka 6 et
7 un jour pourquoi pas quadrillage 5
malgache cinq j'aime bien cette série si
ses intérêts bien quand même
tu as affaire cassé cet je pense à lui
elle veut vraiment péché ces six
clairement bas et c'est cool c'est cool
mais reina qui résistent chancy vanina
gagne ça là le redevient favorite du
match si elle perd ses presque game en
cas de nul
c'est anna favorite mais pas si clair
elle joue tellement vite
vanina c'est marrant qu'elle refuse
vraiment joué ces six même maintenant je
pense encore une bonne solution
thuram est une tour anciens car ayant eu
on va voir on n'était pas loin de game 1
mais peut-être à troyes b 4 ouais c'est
ça c'est une vieille partie connue je me
rappelle plus des noms avec cette
structure là mais aussi les noirs
réussissent pas jouer 5 c'est terrible
chandra juste faire à 3 et essayer de se
placer devant les pions tomber ainsi
très bien elle va peut-être peut jouer
aussi joué avec un 4b 5 celle ci soit
elle à quatre baies 5 c6 très bien
réussi ouais c'est encore mieux jouer
vraiment bien joué la halle elle a bien
joué
alors elle n'a pas voulu faire 6 elle
voulait attendre ce changement de
structure à la vanille n'a dans le dur à
elle si elle perd cela ça va être dur
voilà c'est très dur là trois points
d'écart en plus ça ça tue c'est quasi
game c'est quasi game food et 4 elle
empêche 5 sur m6 sur age iii le carré
lisse bar avec la radio 5 et 6 qui peut
arriver aussi
c'est quasi game h3 ça se sait mange pas
de pain chasse le cac valeo mais le
cavalier h trois cavaliers six cavaliers
5 et 6 franchement ce terrible hein mais
carrillo 5 la caille b3 peut-être 17
c'est bien mais elle va venir en d4 avec
l'autre alors pu faire qui est des 4 5
et 6 et 6 bon elle vit quand même
c'était bien pierre qui a valu aux cinq
direct peut-être qu'il y ait des 4 pts
et 6
franchement la qualité de jeu est bien
plus élevé dans ces matchs que dans les
autres beaucoup moins de gaffes
c'était quand même un peu on en a un peu
suez à l'est qui en d6 soit à 5 c'est
bien et b6 as fantastique elf elf elf et
bien là il ya ça attaque et du coup
c'est 600 premiers alors être le fou en
g3 a laissé bien fou j'ai trois des six
bessette est un petit coup de dams et 5
du coup ici c'est très bien aussi en
plus bessette qui est blessé qui ont
meublé cette tour ces deux il y aura
plus on prend 8 qui refait une dame
c'est game c'est game c'est game les
amis x games ces morts là
le score enfle et c7 vous prend des six
même temps français 6 pouces et 5 est
envoyé sur tours s'est vite tu peux même
bessette tout reprend dame prend tout
reprend et b 8 dames
donc elle empêche le pion qui arrive en
b cette dame 17
ok elle réussit à ok si elle gagne le
pion bessette par un miracle ça peut
aller
enfin ça peut aller sans retour c'est
cette dame madame là pourquoi pas il n'y
a pas tout reprend ya ya ça qui est
pénible donc là la dame va venir en a 6
il ya ça qui va être attaqué voilà
réussit pas à gagner le pion bessette
malheureusement ce n'était pas loin
ce n'est pas loin c'est triste c'est
très triste
c'est très très tristes a le 5 des cas
tu as peut-être encore un ya plus de
temps aux le craquage yade à m dos dames
g2 mais oui mais oui mais oui petit mais
où il mais bravo assez bien joué c'est
bien joué c'est bien joué vanina vanina
qui est là à saillon j'ai dit qu'il y
avait plus de gafsa et c'est reparti
c'est reparti dans la gaffe adha ça
faisait longtemps là on s'ennuie un peu
dans ce match c'est bien ses revenus ses
revenus mais bien sûr ouais c'est abusé
quand même ce second cas de l'essai d'un
f2 dame j'ai deux prêts vanina qui va
gagner
vanina qui a fait craquer
c'est la pls incroyable raté sa voile a
gagné le fief elle aurait pu rentrer
dans un truc plus simple je pense avec
bessette quart allait prendre si on
prend tout reprend si on prend briserait
quoique je comprends qu'elle soit pas
rentrer là dedans t'es pas si sûr que ça
de la gagner brahms et nantua j'avais de
prendre un truc pareil
mais bon pas assez forte avec peu de
temps allez on va partir pour la
dernière portion il ya 4 3
allez vanina qui remonte à l'est ont
refait un sondage va pouvoir si si on
avait raison là vous étiez timmer si
mouche et nina gt gt seul contre tous
j'étais seul contre tous je lui ai dit
vanina va remonter voilà mon avis elle à
intel en tel ascendant psychologique
allez les amis tout va se jouer
maintenant tout va se jouer maintenant
tout va se jouer dans les dernières dans
les derniers hectomètres les amis
allez moi je remets team green in a dit
me vanina je suis de nouveau là c'est
chaud avec même pas mal qui sont contre
moi à l'est boris ou cas annoncés ou
chez nina qui repart devant c'est
incroyable c'est incroyable la dominer à
chaque partie mais justement maugrey
elle est dominée à chaque partie c'est
pour ça qu'elle va gagner c'est pour ça
qu'elle va gagner les amis elle est
tellement dominé elle doit tellement
c'est tellement un miracle d'être à un
point
il faudra faire un autre un autre un
autre vote après on repart en live
direct après genre on enchaîne direct on
repart en live à 18h30
c'est ça la question qu'on se pose sera
le deuxième vote c'est à 20h du coup la
sélection karim a écrit à man ou pas
donc je suis un peu tous les trucs qui a
la main pendant qui m'écrit pas c est
après on va repartir à 18h30 je pense
ça se termine plus tard non mais ça ne
servira pas forcément plus tard ça va de
toute façon se terminer tard dans tous
les cas
quoi qu'il en soit
je sais pas si ça va partir j'ai pas la
prochaine fois que ça à partir en stream
avec étoile ou avec ou avec cam et au
sepa en vrai
avec cam et au jeu pareil ça repart en
stream la semaine prochaine et calmes et
au même antoine non arrête antoine
daniel seraient intéressés vous avez
vous avez vu antoine daniel qui
voulaient se mettre aux échecs n'ont
arrêté c'est une grosse info ça je
regardais en toile daniel quand
j'habitais encore en russie et avec la
fameuse vidéo c'est comme ça en russie
ça se passe comme ça en russie c'est ça
se passe comme ça en russie non sérieux
antoine daniel non arrêtez les gars
n'ont arrêté je peux pas croire ça non
live avec antoine daniel c'est trop pour
moi non arrête pas et c'est normal en
russie n'en arrête arrêter ça si antoine
daniel mme écrit sur twitter pour faire
des échecs j'arrête tout non arrêtent
leur antoine daniel s'est tous battus
pour moi by c'est normal en russie et en
plus c'est vraiment ce qui montrait ses
des vidéos que je connaissais plus ou
moins réussies et où il m'avait fait
trop délirer avec barrette demandez lui
en live bien météo pas très régulier
sera pas la rigueur des échecs on verra
on verra
marc antoine daniel c'est trop pour moi
ce gars est juste ouf sa chaîne youtube
était juste incroyable
ainsi antoine dannielou head coach c'est
fini les gars n'ont qu'à mais kamel il
peut être bon étoiles c'est clair que
étoiles c'est clair qu'il a il à la
rigueur et tout mais kamel ça peut être
tu as ça peut être un bon joueur de café
tu vois kamel c'est un peu le même style
que moi je sens no no no joke kamel et
moi on a à peu près le même style aux
échecs no joke km je sens je sens une
ressemblance dans le style non mais là
avec antoine daniel vous avez 3 alpes
là c'est trop entraîner c'est tellement
c'est tellement un truc de ouf même
s'escrime je regarde de temps en temps
ils sont tellement posez pas que les
autres soient pas posée mais ça fait
quand même longtemps tu vois c'est plus
ma génération en terme de deux streams
games et en terme en termes de tout en
fait d'après ge qui frime avec les
autres aussi mais ils sont plus jeunes
en toile d'année c'est plus ma
génération dans la vous m'avez fait suer
vous voulez me faire ce que vous avez
réussi à me faire suer c'est je sus il
fait du chiot gesser avec étoile a du
coup ça m'étonne pas et toi là du leur
en parler étoiles c'est un gars sur un
maman thuan daniel c'est du très très
lourd
vous avez réussi à me faire suer [ __ ]
bon allez on va se lancer pour pour les
bulles être les amis allez on va se
faire une bonne session de commentaires
là on va se faire plein ouais non
antoine j'étais un peu sur les questions
pour un champion hier sérieux c'était
cool et antoine ses toiles c'est mon
agent way toile à étoile celle
infiltrait des échecs en vrai
en vrai en vrai c'est l'un filtrer
mais kamel ouais je sens un peu le même
style que moi tu vois il vas y vas être
malin étoiles et c'est parti les amis
pour cette section de bullet
je vous rappelle un haouch et nina qui
domine ce match ans elle mène 4 3 elle
aurait pu mener sur sur un score
beaucoup plus large 5-2 ou même voir six
ans aurait été peut-être un score plus
logique mais elle a raté des occasions
on va voir si elle réussit à se remettre
psychologiquement ou si finalement
valentina a pris l'ascendant physique et
psychologique à mon sens vanina plus
plus en forme plus plus punchy là sur
cette fin de match sarr joue un pion
isolée elle avait mis le cavalier e 5
tout à l'heure il est peut-être eu des
dommages 5 qui avait traîné
c'est une position qui lui convient qui
a valu aux cinq tours des trois-tours h3
j'ai envie de te dire à la mûre tasse à
l'ailé change des fous de cases noires
c'est une bonne idée non
sa honte les échanges pas on les garde
on va voir on va voir comment ça évolue
de fou qui vient en c3 allez va falloir
retourner avec des convictions la côte
est côté valentina a poussé un là ça va
partir tour des trois dents tour c'est
un sage ou un peu un peu mou côté
valentina qui a peut-être été un petit
peu rafraîchi par par les grosses
défenses de dana jusqu'à maintenant et
donc ça joue peut-être plus
tranquillement aller le naturel revient
au galop le fou en c2 ça tape le rock
allez on va envoyer le fonds a eu quatre
la dame en f3 les pions aller vanina qui
va jouer l attaque à fond
le petit fois ci ce qui fait plaisir il
va y avoir tous rêvent futures tours 8
ouf ou g7 la dame qui vient en d2 allez
on sent que ça vise le roi fond c'est
bien c'est ce qu'on veut des convictions
du courage et de la discipline côté côté
valentina qui voudraient bien voyage 4 h
5 min à cavalière c'est un cocktail qui
ont des quatre en l'air à les cavaliers
f5 y aura foule prend fc incombe d un
glass à menaces maths en un c'est paraît
il ya fouet 4 qui menace de gagner une
pièce annonce à gagner pas de place à ce
moment-là elle l'a pas fait donc ça aide
quand j'enlève cinq dames e3 est allée
elle va essayer d'envoyer hk tel peut
pas y avait six pour le moment les deux
héros il ya tout reproche 5les à mi
temps prend 1,5
elle est complètement dominé vanina dans
cette partie allait faut abandonner faut
abandonner la vanina faux faux faux
changer de parti là ça sert à rien de
clair du temps il n'y a pas énormément
de deux parties essaient games l'a déjà
un pour prendre rang il ya quand même
pièce pièces de moins nettes sert à rien
de s'entêter à jouer cette finale à
perdre du temps à ces bêtes là de
continuer normes et tu veux pas jouer ça
doit elle doit elle doit elle doit elle
doit mettre son égo
tela valentina ait abandonné peut pas se
permettre de jouer cette finale pendant
des plombes elle doit abandonner voilà
c'est bien elle a perdu la partie
mais elle va repartir allez avec les
noirs il faut vraiment vraiment vraiment
que valentina recollant quatre défaites
il resterait deux parties normalement ça
pourrait être finie valentina au pied du
lion dans ce match est un acquis et lui
sort un petit système de long de la le
pouvoir repartir en 3 afu g5 puis fouet
trois c'est dommage donc elle va être
changée en recettes faire g3 une
position assez égal alors les noirs ou
encore le problème de sousse et 8 mai
valentina voilà l envoi f5 f4 ça y est
elle retrouve son style légendaire
valentina et elle va envoyer à fond sur
le roi adverse
allez il faut y aller fou 17 tours 8 il
faut envoyer la food & 7 ou 8 x 5 mm
il faut y aller à fond allez allez
vanina on se bat on joue à fond on en
voit ça va bien se passer bien se passer
ne t'inquiète pas alors le cavalier qui
vise 5 a objectivement la position est
quand même bien un avantage pour les
blancs le pion aux six arriérés le bon
fou contre le mauvais fou mais ça ça
peut ça peut jouer dommage que sky soit
pas en dé 6,1 d'ailleurs c'est l'autre
qui vient et cavaliers aux sept
cavaliers ap cinq à les pousser 8 on
range le fou on va aller on va on va on
va voir on va naviguer avec les cavales
46 secondes contre 56 mais c'est
difficile difficile pour valentina qui
réussit pas à s'imposer
imposs ton jeu valentina impose ton jeu
si tu veux revenir dans ce match parce
que là c'est que des positions
stratégiques de fond de court valentina
qui réussit pas à attaquer une seule
fois et ana ou chez nina tel un boa
constrictor un boa constrictor pardon
qui est en train de l'étouffer
complètement là sa menace déjà g4 et
prises des 5 la même g4 est jouable pour
chasser le cavalier mais elle va rejouer
le pion aux six la case de 5 c'est
insupportable a joué pour les noirs
allez il faut résister il faut tenir
côté côté noir pour le moment il n'y a
pas de matos en moins peut-être une
nulle mais c'est pas dit qu'on ait deux
parties derrière un nom qu'une nul peut
aussi avantagé les blancs parce que
c'est une partie à mon avis qui va
avoisiner les 80 coup ci s'il est noir
venait à l'emporter donc on voit
toujours ce même problème du pion aussi
ce qui est vie c'est le bon
vous contre le mauvais faux mauvais fond
en 17 et les blancs qui travaille au
corps qui travaillent le pion aux six
peut-être faire du cahier des trois on
va remettre une tour ou cinq on va
mettre un pion dans ces quatre là
évidemment key c5 ou cavaliers 5
ça travaille ça travaille dur le
cavalier et chasser cavalli à vii on va
repartir en f3 non elle va prendre à
tout reprend elle laisse le pion aux si
je pensais qu'ils avaient roi prend mais
y avait peut-être f5 donc tout reprend
1,6 ou chez nina qui vient de travailler
la partie pendant une bonne vingtaine de
coups qui gagne le pion et maintenant
qui va avancer
valentina qui réussit pas du tout à
faire parler ses points forts elle a été
complètement prise dans les ouvertures
dans ce match et on est peut-être en
train de l'avoir payé le prix d'une
meilleure près présentation préparation
côté côté ou chez nina bon allez il va
fort percée maintenant côté ukrainien
mais savait que même si la partie dû
endurer que ça fait nul ça peut faire
game 1 là maintenant elle attaque le
pion il va y avoir g63 allard wife 6
ouais là ça ça se passe toujours aussi
bien pour les blancs toujours pas de
gaffe menace tous rêvent cinq échecs
séparé allez il faut faut peut-être un
tour h5 maintenant oualata crois
j'essais 3e 5 et ça va rentrer avec roy
prend des cinq ça semble aller tout
reprend ainsi sa paire ouais non elle va
pas le faire il est toujours aussi ses
échecs et maintenant ces quatre rois
bush des saints quoi ça a fair game ccc
fait les amis c'est quasiment fait allez
un petit peu de contre jeu peut-être
avec une tour arrive de tours prend b2
allait peut-être un dernier espoir la
tour 5 semble faire mal il faut aller
prendre le pion sacrifié en c6 tu as
peut-être pas le choix ou rouge et
quatre pouces et 8 et essayer de essayé
d'envoyer ce qui reste n'y reste pas
grand chose des amis à tour qui arrive
en hausse est ouest et la catastrophe
croit ses sept tours à 7 et j'ai cette
fois je sais tu mates
c'est fini ça fait maintenant trois
points d'écart et valentina ballantyne à
là c'est fini il y aura pas trois
parties je vais vous dire officiellement
qu'on me et reste de temps mais mais
j'ai envie de vous dire il en reste pas
beaucoup ça on le sait on le sait les
amis il peut pas il peut pas rester même
plus de cinq minutes là il reste 3
minutes 30
il faudrait gagner deux parties en 3 30
c'est absolument impossible les amis et
sanaa où
chez nina qui va remporter cette
première manche
qui alors a vraiment dominé un bras bien
joué dans tous les matches je pense que
seules joueuses jouent d'un sur les
échecs pure sans compter la connexion
aurait aurait pu aurait pu la gêne et
elle a vraiment été très forte
aujourd'hui
valentina qui qui était en dessous peut
pas vraiment dire qu'elle est qu'elle
ait raté le match à un moment un moment
précis elle était juste un petit peu
moins forte mais à mais je penserai dans
les ouvertures s'est mieux passée à l'as
jamais réussi à imposer son style de jeu
son style offensif qui a jamais qui a
jamais pu s'allumer hier un quand caen
lorsqu'elle a joué contre kosteniuk
vendredi est là elle a pu jouer son jeu
d'attaqué mais là aujourd'hui elle a
jamais réussi à le mettre en place
anna était vraiment très solide à
l'inquiéter championne du monde qui a
vraiment été impressionnant dans ce
match dans cette compétition mais qui
aura vraiment dominé tout le monde est
une des six adams et trois peut-être
maintenant pour essayer de taper un peu
sur le pion à deux ans de toute façon
comme je disais il fallait à 2 victoires
en 3 30
pour avoir une chance avec la première
partie va durer plus de trois minutes
plus de trois minutes donc c'est assez
complètement fini d'être cavalière 4 et
6 heures possible et cavaliers des cinq
ouais ça en plus les noirs qui domine sa
salle bien fait cavaliers au 6bisarts
voir me suis là mais valentina valentina
qui va laisser la victoire s'échapper
elle qui s'était qualifié au dernier
moment pour pour ces grands prix mais
elle pourra elle pourra encore faire
valoir ses qualités uns dans les autres
grands prix elle retourne un peu la
situation
mais quoi qu'il en soit elle est loin
loin derrière
a man show commencera mercredi
commencera mercredi il y aura quatre
manches qui commenceront toujours le
mercredi dans la prochaine mensura la
grande favorite du tournoi ou ifan qu'on
suivra avec attention et délectation
j'ai envie de dire n'ayons pas peur des
mots
bon allez valentina qui va la gagner
celle-là comme je disais de toute façon
ça va durer durer et durer durer et
durer la taxe sur le roi est puissante
et il restera peut-être a plus que
quelques secondes pour remporter la
partie d'après il faut ici de défendre
côté anna le plus longtemps possible
histoire de vraiment s'assurer la
victoire
mais j'ai pas j'ai même pas envie de
vous de vous donner un faux suspense
puisque suspense il n'y a plus ça va
mater au elle donne la dame en un
incroyable
oh là là le boit le calice jusqu'à la
lie olala damage sept matches en un raté
et elle fait dame g7
elle n'était pas dans un grand jour un
valentina qui s'est fait un drain qui
s'est fait éteindre
elle s'est complètement fait doucher par
parra n'a plus de confiance elle a
vraiment raté ma temps l'un pour donner
une dame
c'est quelque chose de très très rare
mais bon dans tous les cas le match
était perdu c'est anecdotique 1 mais là
quand même
blender m'attendait pour donner une dame
c'est rarissime mais moi ça m'arrive pas
souvent ici pour dire c'est pour dire
c'est rare mais après le match est perdu
et psychologiquement un valentina qui
est une joueuse de rush forcément
psychologiquement les défaites
l'enchaînement des défaites lui ont fait
mal non mais le match façon comme je
disais était plié donc c'est hyper
anecdotique
star missclick missclick qui changera
rien du coup puis pas comment vu sa tête
c'est vrai je passe c'était un mystique
où pas moins de façon comme je disais ça
change rien il y aurait il y aurait eu
il y aurait eu 6 4 et je pense que là le
times et over je pense que le times est
over je vais vérifier voit le times et à
pour être de toute façon comme je vous
disais c'est ça aurait été dommage hein
de sueur sur un truc décisif je taime
over ouais c'est game chine en plus face
on est là quoi qu'il en soit de façon à
les deux nouveaux foutu bon elle va
peut-être la gagner ou quoi mais âge et
en plus je viens vraiment vraiment pas
de regret la sueur service click mais
grosse grosse démonstration ce sera
l'algérie ou le villa dans ce soir ce
sera le couscous ce soir comme on a
gagné les derniers matches comme on sort
on sort on sort de victoire en match en
match
ce sera le couscous
couscous ce soir
partis à la casse qui va se terminer
bientôt donc ce soir
ouais on va je reprends le peut-être je
fais un peu de partie pédagogique dans
un premier temps ça commence commence à
être plus chaud pour pour un arrêt en
kaki en c4 sévère qui alors je pense
18h30 à peu près 18h30 19h je pense va
essayer 18h30 je faire une petite pause
je sais d un peu récupéré cherche à
nkembo couler ce crime en ce moment
c'est le fond de court à les pions en b3
c'est pas si clair là
les joueuses qui ont quand même envie de
gagner c'est un truc qui va toujours
surpris en fait genre là avec les blancs
jouent avec le temps est terminé je vois
que j'ai gagné le match c'est peut-être
mon problème moi je galérais pas pour
essayer de la gagner j'aurais fait le
taff m'en fiche royal ce cas tu sais que
tu as gagné le match
je suis très peu le trait
comme je disais mc gagnerie 6 4 il y
aurait 6 5 il n'aurait jamais eu mieux
koala given celle gagnée par le temps
pas le pourri give up way avec les
blancs avec les noirs pardon avec les
blancs pas avec les deux en fait
mais bon je comprends plus ce que tu as
envie de gagner avec les noirs on a en
fait elle joue le temps m non ça sont
valides à l'aller c'est que le match est
fini
elle le savait de toute façon dès
qu'elle a perdue avec dame g7 mais même
avant en fait c'était c'était sûr que
c'était perdu donc match gagné à part ou
chez nina qui remporte la compétition et
du coup on se retrouve donc j'imagine
dans un peu moins d'une heure pour le
prochain match pour le prochain match
pour le match contre les bras contre les
pieds et donc bravo à hanau chez nina
qui remporte le tournoi est filmé devant
valentine agouni n'a donc deuxièmes et
alexandra kosteniuk qui prend la
troisième place elles ont pris quelques
points pour les grands prix je crois 12
10 et 8 et après ses sept ça descend
puis si c'est petit à petit ça descend
mais sans n'en parlera plus avec le 2e
3e grand prix avec les nouvelles
joueuses pour essayer de se faire un
tableau on en parlera plus à partir de
la prochaine fois d'ailleurs c'était pas
le premier tour ici c'était écrit
premier tour mais c'était bien la finale
c'était la finale ici même en finale au
bon endroit dans son mais quasiment
jamais passer sur cet écran on est tout
le temps avec les calmes
donc merci à tous à tout à l'heure merci
encore et à mercredi prochain du coup
pour le deuxième
la deuxième phase avec la grande
favorite